bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pendant la suspension
des travaux du Sénat je vous propose de
voir ou de revoir les temps forts de la
dernière session parlementaire ce matin
je vous propose de revenir aux travaux
de la commission des finances sur
l'évasion et la fraude fiscale dans le
siage des révélations des Panama papers
la commission des finances a effectué au
printemps et all l'été des auditions sur
ces thèmes elle a concentré une partie
de ses efforts sur les banques et elle a
ainsi vu s'exprimer la Société Générale
le 11 mai puis le Crédit Agricole et la
BNP pariba le 25 toutes ces banques ont
été je vous le rappel mise en cause dans
le scandale panaméen je vous propose de
revoir tout d'abord ce matin l'audition
de Philippe Brassac le directeur général
du groupe Crédit Agricole qui a commencé
par donner des détails plutôt précis sur
l'organisation de la banque pour lui la
la gestion d'activités offshore la
présence dans les territoires non
coopératifs tout cela et bien c'est du
passé mais vous allez le voir il n'a pas
convaincu tout le monde puisqu'il a dû
faire face à des questions sur la façon
dont la banque externalise aujourd'hui
ce type d'activité voyez cette audition
qui date du 25 mai je vais peut-être
d'abord répondre à une question que
d'cun peuvent se poser comment se
fait-il que le groupe récool dont on
connaît l'historique plutôt rurale et
française puisse être significativement
concerné par la Banque Privée intern
nationale en réalité nous sommes très
présents dans la banque privée y compris
internationale notamment depuis
l'acquisition d'indosues en
1995 et du groupe Crédit lyonnaet en
2003 c'est une activité qui n'est pas
négligeable chez nous mais que j'oserai
qume qualifier de marginal puisque la
Banque Privée internationale dans le
groupe
crédéagricole représente 2,4 % de nos
revenus de notre produit net bancaire
dont 0,9 % hors Europe et c'est
évidemment hors Europe que se situent
notamment les activités dites des
structures
offshore je vais donc comme vous m
invité vous faire le point sur le chemin
que nous avons parcouru depuis 2010 au
CR agricole s'agissant de notre
organisation pour lutter de la façon la
plus efficace possible contre l'évasion
fiscale au-delà de ce que nous faisons
et nous devons faire pour lutter contre
le blanchiment et le financement du
terrorisme le groupericole en œuvre
trois types de mesures depuis 2010 que
je vais préciser tout de suite en 2010
la décision a été prise de nous retirer
physiquement en terme de structure de
banque privée international des
territoires que nous qualifions de non
coopératif une liste de 14 pays qui au
passage je le souligne une liste plus
large que celle qui était publiée par la
commission des finances et c'est ainsi
que nous sommes sortis des îles Caillan
des îles Vierges britanniques et des
Bahamas en 2012 nous avons pris une
autre décision que je voudrais souligner
parce que je pense qu'elle est
singulière nous avons aussi décidé de
mettre fin à toute activité de
prestation pour autant licite mais toute
activité de prestation s'agissant de ce
qu'on appelle le conseil en fidu
c'est-à-dire l'intermédiation le conseil
la création ou la gestion de structures
dites offshore et pour pour laquelle
cette
activité nous avons eu recours à
différents types d'intermédiaires dont
le cabinet Moussac fonsseeka que madame
la Présidente vous
citiez je voudrais souligner que ces
deux mouvements de sortie des
territoires non coopératives décidé en
2010 et le l'arrêt de toute activité de
conseil et de prestation sur les
structures offshore ont été totalement
achevé en 2015 et que tout ceci relève
donc pour nous totalement du passé
l'arrêt de l'activité c'est en fait soit
par cession de structure soit par
extinction de ce type
d'activité mais nous avons rajouté une
troisième décision qui au fond d'une
certaine façon fait la preuve sur les
deux premières parce qu'elle écrase tout
en terme de preuve en 2013 nous avons
décidé de
revérifier la rectitude fiscale de
l'ensemble de nos clientèles de la
Banque Privée internationale je dis bien
tous nos clients c'est-à-dire aussi bien
les ayant des structures offshore les
ayant droit des structures enshore parce
qu'évidemment il en existe par exemple
des structures européennes pour des
européens mais aussi des personnes
physiques qui au total représentent une
clientèle d'environ 70000 clients pour
le groupe
récole ce travail d'exigence de preuve
et de revérification de rectitude
fiscale a été achevé pour tous les
résidents français fin
2014 pour tous les clients de l'Union
européenne fin 2015 et nous avons
entrepris ce travail là pour les
clientèles de reste du monde en mars
2015 il devrait s'achever fin 2016 pour
toutes les structures et en 2017 pour
les personnes
physiques s'agissant des volumétrie et
donc des du nombre de structures
offshore dites toujours Activ
c'est-à-dire toujours clientes du Crédit
Agricole dans nos
structures notamment au Luxembourg en
Suisse et à Monaco
alors j'ai essayé d'être le plus clair
possible là-dessus si on prend d'abord
l'axe mossac
Fonseca nous avons aujourd'hui encore au
Panama 11 structures
offshore dont je le soulligne zéro et
enoit
français si nous prenons toujours mossac
Fonseca mais que nous l'étendons à tous
les territoires pour lequel mossac
Fonseca pouveit travailler nous avons 80
structures offshore dont toujours zéro
euh résident français et pour être le
plus complet possible si je prends les
différents prestataires type mossac
fonseeka qui travaille dans ce type
d'activité et qui continue à travailler
dans ce type d'activité si je prends le
territoire Panama nous avons quatre
structures concernant des résidents
français et si je prends l'ensemble des
territoires c'est-à-dire tout
prestataire et tout territoire nous
avons 23 structures correspondant à
desendroits français je rajoute tout de
suite c'est très important que pour
autant toutes ces clientèles là ont été
vérifié fiscalement et que de toute
manière comme nous opérons à partir de
l'Europe toutes ces clientèles là
rentreront dans l'échange automatique
d'information des 2017 ou 2018 et les
clientèles le
savent voilà pour terminer je voudrais
en profiter pour résumer la politique du
groupe Crédit Agricole en terme de
banque privée internationale parce que
que ce que nous a enseigné ce que m'a
enseigné plus personnellement l'affaire
dite des Panama papers c'est au fond la
chose suivante je crois qu'on peut faire
le constat qu'aujourd'hui il ne suffit
pas de respecter strictement les
différentes réglementations des
différents pays dans lequel nous opérons
si en même temps nous ne sommes pas
suffisamment lisibles extérieurement de
façon simple et non équivoque sur ce
qu'on va appeler nos champs
d'acceptabilité et nos champs de non
acceptabilité la du groupe cré agricole
se formule donc de la façon suivante
nous ne voulons être présent en banque
privée internationale que dans les
territoire qui s'engag dans l'échange
automatique d'information et nous
voulons y accepter que des clients qui
peuvent et nous donne le mandat
d'échange automatique d'information ce
qui signifie à contrario qu'il n'y a pas
de bénéfice du doute pour toutes les
clientèles pour lesquelles nous ne
pouvons pas matériellement faire ces
vérifications parce que les États ne
coopéra pas sous forme d'accords
bilatéraux ou multilatéraux voilà madame
la Présidente les quelques informations
que je souhaitais vous livré pour cadrer
le dispositif du groupe cragricole sur
le sujet pour lequel nous sommes
auditionnés merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur général je je vous remercie de
ces précisions très précises pour le
coup
euh mais tout de même afin qu'il pas
d'ambiguité
euh vous nous dites que vous avez mis
fin définitivement aux activités de
service offshore c'est-à-dire à
l'ouverture et la gestion de société
écan
mais est-ce que cette activité n'a pas
été externalisée d'une certaine manière
afin de la sortir du bilan de la banque
en continuant à offrir des services aux
clients et je vais être plus
précise le Crédit Agricole Suisse
conseil casque filiale de la banque pour
les activités offshore n'a en effet pas
été liquidé
mais vendu au groupe mauritien
NWT reatisé NWT conseil qui permet au
créditcool faire sortir de son bilan
plus de la moitié des sociétés offshore
qu'il gérait selon des informations de
presse NVT conseil continuerait à
fonctionner avec d'anciens employés
système de casque et servir des clients
avec en lien étroit avec le Crédit
Agricole Suisse et ses
filiales et deux entités qui apporté des
services fuduci ont été cédés en 2012
vous nous l'avez dit d'ailleurs Crédit
Agricole management service banamas et
Crédit Agricole Suisse conseil mais
est-ce que ces deux activités ont été
réellement
scindées avez-vous gardé des liens avec
vos anciennes filiales fiduciaires
capitalistique ou d'une autre nature y
compris
informelle quelle est votre relation
avec les clients de ces filiales
notamment quand il s'agit de clients que
vous avez
redirigé vers l'opération offshore par
le passé moi je voudrais être sûr que le
crédit agcole ne propose plus à ses
clients de mettre en place des sociétés
écran que ce soit directement ça il me
semble que vous l'avez précisé via une
filiale ou via un partenaire y compris
de façon
informelle voilà ma première question si
vous voulez bien y répondreessayer d'y
répondre très précisément permettez-moi
au préalable de souligner que ce type
d'AC ité parfaitement liible etue à être
opéré par des grandes banques y compris
en
France donc je ne dis pas que nous avons
abandonné une activité illicite nous
faisons le choix politique de ne plus
conseiller structurer et gérer ce type
de structure alors même que d'autres le
font et donc dans l'opération de cession
nous avons soit mis en extinction ce
type de prestation soit nous avons cédé
certes à des prestataires externes qui
sont parfaitement connus et pour lequels
nous n'avons sinon ça n'aurait aucun
sens comme nous ne sommes pas pas
contraint à cela pour lesquels nous
n'avons passé aucun type d'accord
commercial puisque nous ne voulons plus
être dans au fond la genèse du Conseil
pas pour des raisons réglementaires nous
avons parfaitement le droit de le faire
mais au fond pour des raisons de
lisibilité de notre politique pour qu'il
n'y ait aucun doute sur tout ceci donc
oui nous avons complètement cédé aux
structures que que vous citez il n'y a
pas de lien commercial il n'y a pas
d'engagement d'affaair avec eux et
surtout notre politique a été
explicitement écrite de ne pas
conseiller de ne pas structurer de ne
pas gérer même si des clientèles peuvent
évidemment aller s'adresser à ce type de
de structure je je voudrais enfin
préciser que vous vous vous utilisez le
terme d'écran matériellement ou
physiquement cela paraît ainsi mais
l'échange automatique d'information a
complètement changé la donne ou dès lors
que vous opérez sur des territoires
c'est le cas avec le Luxembourg la
Suisse et Monaco à partir de clientèle
dont les pays respectifs s'engagent dans
l'change automatique d'information il
n'y a plus d'opacité possible et donc je
voudrais simplement ne pas ne pas
stigmatiser le fait que des structures
offshore puissent exister elles sont
utiles par ailleurs on pourra répondre à
vos questions légitimes sur à quoi peut
servir une structure offshore si ce
n'est pas pour de l'évasion fiscale mais
dans tous les cas du fait de notre
politique lorsque nous sommes à
Luxembourg Suisse Monaco avec notamment
des résidents français ces information
seront automatiquement diffusé au
différents fisques être très concret
pardon je termine là-dessus lorsque nous
sommes en Suisse aujourd'hui en 2018 et
les clients le savent l'information sera
pour n clients français automatiquement
donné au fix fr au fisque Suisse pardon
qui devra automatiquement les donner au
FIS
français merci beaucoup ben écoutez
pourquoi ne pas le dire tout de suite
une société offshore vous dites pas
seulement évasion fiscale cétait c'est
c'est pourquoi puis qu'on nous a parlé
beaucoup de patrimoine est-ce que voilà
alors je je vais peut-être laisser Jean
yocher qui est le patron des activités
grande clientèle à la fois grande
entreprise et puis grande clientèle
personnelle développer parce que je
pense que c'est le point le plus
important de comprendre que ces
structures offshore existent elles
peuvent dissimuler de l'évasion fiscale
notre politique nous met à l'abri de ce
type de risque considérant que nous
allons jouer totalement dans le dans le
cercle de l'échange de automatique
d'information mais il est important
d'expliquer pourquoi pour les
clientelles fortunées ce type de
structuration peut exister peut-être
opportune sans aucune opacité
fiscale il n'y a pas d'autres il n'y a
pas d'autres véhicules
français euh suffisamment souple qui
permettrait d'atteindre le même but
alors Jean va vous répondre à cette
question là mais on va par exemple
parler de d'investissement à l'étranger
une personne fortunée en France peut
évidemment faire des acquisitions à
l'international il y a besoin de
structurer de façon finalement euh
juridique de la façon la plus souple
possible ceci la vraie question que vous
posez légitimement c'est est-ce que ceci
permet de faire écran fiscalement
probablement dans le temps dans le passé
selon comment vous opérez la réponse est
oui mais selon comme vous opérez
c'està-d si vous êtes totalement dans le
cercle de ceux qui sont dans l'échange
automatique d'information que nous
souhaitions et que nous approuvons c'est
une très bonne chose que les États
aillent de plus en plus loin dans
l'échange automatique d'information
cette opacité ne peut plus exister et
nous prédécool nous faisons le choix de
nous pérer plus que dans le comment dire
cet intra échange automatique
d'information Jean peut-être tu peux
donner très concrètement des exemples de
d'usage euh monsieur auch merci présent
je dirais qu'il y a trois quatre grand
de causes classiques de création de de
structure offshore
par des résidents souvent très fortunés
qui vont diversifier leur patrimoine à
travers le
monde la première cause je pense c'est
la la cause
immobilière de gens qui acquièrent des
immeubles dans divers
pays les places dans ce type de de
structure a priori il y a pas de de
difficulté fiscale puisque selon la
convention OCDE qui est appliqué dans la
plupart des pays les meubles sont
fiscalisés dans le pays de
l'immeuble bon c'est c'est plutôt une
une raison générale l'organisation du
patrimoine placer tous les immeubles
qu'on possède à travers le monde dans la
même société quoi c'est plus c'est plus
commode la deuxème grande
cause c'est une cause plutôt technique
de gens qui sont propriétaires d'avion
de y c'est vraiment des gens très très
fortunés avec des équipages dans dans
ces dans ces moyens de transport là on
va retrouver l'organisation assez
classique qu'on trouve pour les
armarteurs Français par exemple he qui
font immatriculer les bateaux dans les
pays dans lesquels l'immatriculation est
simple dans lesquels le droit maritime
est commode et un des exemples qui qui
me vient à l'esprit c'est le fait
que ces bateaux ces avions étant souvent
fiscalisés par
l'emprunt la banque peut assez
facilement en cas de non paiement de du
crédit réaliser le gage c'estàd les
actions de la société voilà donc dans
beaucoup de pays si un emprunteur ne P
pas les loyers de son bateau les
procédures judiciaires vont durer 2 ans
donc là non sont des procédures
judiciaires qui sont extrêmement rapides
d'où le fait que les armateurs ou
professionnel ou à titre personnel et et
recours à ses pavillons il y a une tr è
grande cause très classique là aussi qui
est des organisations succ
successoral qui permettent de faire
primer la la volonté du défunt donc un
exemple ressant qui me vient à l'esprit
une personne qui ne peut pas céder c'est
bien à un enfant
décédé mais seulement à ces petits
enfants les canes sont relativement
jeunes donc dans ce type de juridiction
on peut retarder l'exécution de la
succession jusqu'à la majorité des
petits enfants bon en France par exemple
ça n'est pas possible l'exécution de la
succession elle est elle est
instantané d'ailleurs souvent puis qu'il
faut gérer ses bien le donateur pouvant
être décédé entre-temps fait appel à un
curateur qui va qui va prendre soin de
toute
cette de toute cette affaire assez
complexe on le voit c'est souvent assez
complexe C questions de succession et
puis enfin euh dans certaines parties du
monde les gens ont recours à ce type de
structure dans lesquelles ils mettent
leurs bien pour des raisons de sécurité
physique a des pays qui restent des pays
dangereux ou de sécurité
politique on peut dire par exemple que
la l'immense majorité des résidents
d'Amérique du Sud qui placent leur
argent à Panama en fait pas très loin de
chez eux le place là pour ces raisonsl
qui sont des raisons de sécurité ou
physique ou poli donc voilà les quatre
grandes raisons qu'on des gens très
fortunés d'avoir recours à ces
structures l'immobilier les raisons
technique bateau avion comme les
professionnels finalement euh des
clauses successorales qui veulent
organiser selon leur volonté et puis des
pays un peu difficiles dans lesquels on
met son argent à l'abri à l'extérieur
voilà mais à votre avis il y aurait
quelque chose à faire dans le droit
français pour
euh permettre une souplesse
davantage parce que au fond ce que nous
recherchons nous la commission des
finances c'est d'une part savoir s'il y
a des résidents français concernés vous
avez été assez explicite en la matière
pour ce qui vous concerne mais qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
différemment et la deuxième question
mais je pense que nos collègues seront
heureux de l'entendre et peut-être
certains collègues l'auraient posé
mais les les pavillons dont vous parlez
pour les
bateaux ils sont où à Panama ou un peu
ailleurs aussi ils
sont ils sont à Panama ils sont souvent
à l'île de manne au nord ENF entre
l'Écosse et l'Irlande je pense c'est un
sujet qui a été souvent débattu à la
fois par le gouvernement et par le le
Parlement en France la commodité de ces
immatriculations voilà mais mais pour ce
qui concerne la la la structuration de
ces pavillons en tout cas pour les
banques le critère majeur c'est la
facilité de réalisation du gage un
bateau dont les loyers seront pas payés
peut être saisi en quelques heures quoi
donc la législation française ne permet
pas on est obligé d'avoir recours à des
voix de justice classiqu qui qui sont
qui sont beaucoup plus
compliqué débat politique en France sur
ou oui nous avons eu sur les sur les les
bateaux évidemment monsieur le
rapporteur général mon présidente moi je
vais tout simplement me référer à nos
deux dernières auditions celle du du 11
mai celle du 18 mai c'est du 11 mai
concernant la sociité générale et celle
de Madame houlette la procureur de la
République la financier la semaine
dernière de mémoire
euh Patrick su donc le secrétaire
général de de du groupe Société Générale
avait assuré que la banque et je le cite
ne participait pas bien entendu des
opérations de l'objet exclusivement
fiscal vous savez d'ailleurs c'est c'est
un peu la définition de de l'abus de
droit en matière fiscale donc
concrètement des clients pe vous saisir
pour centre d'opération certaines sont
sont patrimoniales vous avez parlé
d'autres pour objet de de faciliter par
exle les voies de recours ou l'emploi de
personnel quelle serait l'attitude
concrètement euh de créer école si un
client vous saisissait pour une
opération dont l'objet principal ou
quasiment exclusif serait d'éluder
l'impôt ou de d'échapper à l'impôt donc
puis la deuxième question se réfère à ce
que Madame houlette nous disait la
semaine dernière elle nous faisait part
de cette difficulté de la difficulté du
PNF à connaître les bénéficiaaires
réels des trusts donc concrètement nous
disons même par la voie de la
coopération judiciaire on a les plus
nous avons les plus grandes difficultés
à connaître les bénéficiaires réels d'un
trust et ça rejoint d'ailleurs la
difficulté dont faisait état également
la DG FIP qui nous disait même en
matière de coopération fiscale matière
de coopération administrative on a aussi
les plus grandes difficultés à connaître
les bénéficiaires réels d'un trust donc
alors bénéfici effectif alors ma
question est simple comment la banque
comment une banque peut obtenir ces
informations puisque la banque vous avez
des obligations notamment de de
connaissance du client customer donc
comment vous remplissez ces
obligations
connaissantéventuel éventuels
bénéficiaires effectifsun trust et si
vous les connaissez est-ce que vous avez
la possibilité de les transmettre ou
est-ce que vous les transmettezistration
fiscale Monsieur le Directeur oui
monsieur le rapporteur général donc
notre est très simple sur le premier
point et vare très précis sur le second
je n'ai pas qu' a d'ambigité nous ne
cherchons pas au-delà de la recherche
d'évasion fiscale trouver d'autres
objets il ne peut pas y avoir de
recherche d'évasion fiscale dans la
politique que nous avons défini qui est
volontairement limit limité puisque nous
ne voulons opérer qu'à partir de
territoires qui sont dans l'échange
automatique d'information et sur des
clients dont les pays sont dans
l'échange automatique d'information donc
nous sommes restrictifs en ce sens que
j'exprimais tout à l'heure nous ne
laissons pas le bénéfice du doute
lorsque nous ne pouvons pas aller aux
vérifications dès lors qu'il n'y a pas
d'accords bilatéraux multilatéraux par
définition pour nos clientèles de
banquees privé international nous ne
pouvons avoir que des personnes
physiques des structures onshore ou
offshore peu importe au fond où qu'ell
soit et qu'elle soit la forme qui vont
ou qui sont dans leschang automatique
d'information et le mot automatique
parle de lui-même c'estàdire qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'attitude de la banque a
décidé mais au fond le système organisé
entre États je reexlique un instant
comment va cela fonctionne si vous êtes
par exemple cette fois-ci je vais
prendre l'exemple de Luxembourg qui est
dans l'échange automatique d'information
et que vous avez que des clients dans le
territoire et dans leschange automati
d'information c'est le cas par exemple
de toute l'Union européenne et bien la
banque à Luxembourg devra donner
automatiquement toutes les informations
au fisque du Luxembourg il est
retransmet au fisque des pays d'origine
et notamment euh au au pays français
donc nous ne pouvons pas être dans un
système dans une politique où il y
aurait en plus un intérêt d'évasion
fiscale ceci étant comment faisons-nous
pour détecter au départ ceux qui
viendrai pour cela et donc les exclure
de notre fond de commerce euh la réalité
c'est que nous devons effectivement
connaître d'abord no yor customers c'est
connaître les vrais en droits ce n'est
peut-être pas toujours facile mais quand
on pe pas on ne prend pas qu'on nouvre
pas les comptes des clients et des
structures dont on n'est pas sûr d'avoir
les vrais aant droits et dans
l'opération très lourde puisque ces
70000 clients que nous avons entrepris
fini pour les Français fini pour l'Union
européenne et fini pour le reste du
monde dans peu de temps dè lors que nous
ne sommes pas sûrs dans la
revérification fiscale d'avoir tous les
éléments de preuve et toutes les
connaissan sur les ayant droits nous
avons été également amenés à clôturer
ces opérations là et au passage de façon
traçable de façon lisible pour ne pas
permettre une évasion complémentaire
voilà alors peut-être je sais pas si
jeanve a des éléments plus précis sur la
façon dont nos conseillers au fond vont
à la vérification de l'endroit en tout
cas à la fois notre territorialité ne
nous permet pas d'accueillir des clients
qui échapperaient à cette fiscalité par
ailleurs le vrai travail qui nous est
imposé de vérifier la connaissance de
client fait que si nous avons le moindre
doute sur les vrais éendroits nous ne
devons pas prendre et par ailleurs il y
a des mécanismes de déclaration de
soupçon qui dans tous les états sont des
mécanismes de déclaration lorsqu'on a la
crainte d'un blanchiment ou d'un
financement de terrorisme qui dans
certains états de plus en plus pour pas
dire bientôt dans tous c'est le cas de
la France depuis 2009 déclare aussi le
risque d'évasion fiscal puisque c'est
devenu un délit depuis depuis 2009 et
dans les pays qui étaient peut-être
les plus les plus lents aller à ce
processus là vous savez que la Suisse
est en 2016 également
dans comment dire la déclaration
délictueuse de la complicité d'évasion
fiscale PhIP juste ajouter une précision
technique comment est traité le cas
d'une société offshore il en restera l'
dit des sociétés
offshore dont nous tenons des comptes au
Luxembourg nous nous connaissons les
bénéficiire de ces sociétés offshore
parce qu'on n'accepte pas de société
offshore donc on connaît pas tous les T
les
bénfires simpement ce qui est nouveau
c'est que l'échange automatique nous
permet à la fois nous permet et nous
oblige d'ailleurs à transmettre aux
autorités fixales
luxembourgeoise d'une part les avoirs
qui a dans la société et l'identité
fiscale des bénéficiaires de façon à ce
que le Luxembourg transmettre aux
différents pays s'il y en a plusieurs
des bénéficiaires toutes les données
cette cette question de l'éch
automatique c'est vraiment le
sésam qui permet de régulariser la la
situation de façon universelle d'où le
choix fait par le carcole de de ne
nopérer que dans ces pays monsieur le
rapporteur général question
complémentaou parce qu'on parlait du
Luxembourg l'instant et la semaine
dernière le secrétaire général de la CPR
nous a fait part des difficultés à
exercer des contrôles notamment au
Luxembourg puisque très concrètement le
régulateur
luxembourgeois en quelque sorte euh
réalisit lui-même l'échantillon euh sur
lequel les contrôles devaient être fait
et il a équéement la difficulté à
contrôler des filial y compris de banque
française donc est-ce que quelles sont
concrètement est-ce qu'il y a des
instructions qui sont données
euh à vos filiales en cas de contrôle
sur place de coopération avec le
régulateur euh est-ce qu'il y a une
remontée avec le régulateur français en
tout cas c'est la difficulté
que voilà il nous a signalé donc on sait
qu'il y a des contrôles qui sont mal
passés ou pas très bien passés pass
mesure où le régulateur français en
allant sur place seurte finalement à une
faible coopation on est dans un autre
domaine domain fiscal qui à mon sens a
réglé ses problèm régulation a exécution
de de l'échange automatique là on est
dans le domaine de la régulation donc
les instructions qui sont données à nos
filiales étrangères et d'obéir aux
règles du régulateur local local oui on
a guerre le choix donc si le régulateur
local ne veut pas transmettre
d'information
sans accord de coopération juridique
entre les pays nous ne pourouvons
guère ah non la coopération juridique
n'est pas obligatoire régulateur
régulateur la coopération le régulateur
lui est souverain dans son pays peut
décider que les données sont
transmissibles ou pas et souvent décide
qu'elles sont transmissibles s'il y a
accord de coopération juridique qu'il
faut mettre en œuvre donc c'est une
procédure assez longue qui passe par le
ministère de la justice c'est un
procédure qui procédure qui qui se
déroule pas comme ça donc nous nous
obéiss sont régulateur local
évidemment merci merci
messieur je vais donner la parole à nos
collègues qui l'ont sollicité Éric
Boquet en premier lieu il sera suivi de
François Marc bien merci madame la
Présidente bonjour messieurs
effectivement nous sommes plus d'un à
avoir été surpris de d'entendre parler
du crine agricole qui nous avait
davantage habitué dans le temps au bon
sens près de chez nous mais vous n'avez
pas échappé vous non plus à la
mondialisation à la financialisation AC
extrême et vous vous retrouvez un peu
dans la tourmente aujourd'hui cela dit
avant les avant les révélations des
Panama papers un rapport était sorti le
16 mars
2016 organis écrit par différentes ONG
Oxfam le Secours Catholique CCD TER
solidaire qui faisait une analyse
complète de la présence des banques
françaises dans les paradis fiscaux dans
le monde et vous y figuriez bien sûr et
il nous est indiqué dans le document
vous me direz si vous infirmez ou
confirmez qu'en 2 14 vous aviez réalisé
2,4 milliards de bénéfices à
l'international dont 700 millions dans
les paradis fiscaux soit 28,6 % de ce
chiffre donc est-ce que vous confirmez
ou infirmez cette réalité le même
document préciser que sur les 159
filiales de votre groupe figurant dans
les paradis
fiscaux seul SEP entités étai des
banques de détail donc vous avez
commencé à répondre j'allais poser la
question de quel type d'activité vous
menez dans ces filiales mais vous avez
en partie répondu mais est-ce que est-ce
que si c'est transparent est-ce qu'il y
a nécessité absolue d'organiser les
activités patrimoniales successorales
dans des territoires où l'opacité règne
si c'est transparent pourquoi ce
cacher ensuite est venu l'affaire les
révélations des Panama papers évidemment
qui a secoué le monde entier y compris
vous vous n'avez pas été épargné
d'ailleurs le chiffre cité de 1129 neuve
structure offshore géré par vous depuis
depuis plusieurs années est supérieur à
celui qui a été annoncé pour la Société
Général donc vous étiez la première
banque concernée par cette affaire si ce
chiffre est confirmé avec donc le
cabinet mossac fonseeka devenu bien sûr
très célèbre depuis et ce chiffre donc
remonte aux années 90 nous dit le
document euh sur la première réaction de
votre part sur un compte Twitter
apparemment cette activité a cessé en
2015 et Monsieur le Directeur vient de
nous parler de cessation en 2010 donc
s'est-il passé durant ces 5 années et en
2013 on nous parle également de 246
sociétés offshore encore Activ donc il y
a là divergence sur les chiffres
j'aimerais avoir quelques précisions
là-dessus et pouvez-vous certifier et au
besoins surdementand documenter vos vos
informations et vos
affirmations plus tard votre
établissement a publié un communiqué que
je vais me permettre de citer la Banque
Privée du créd agricole a engagé une
démarche volontaire visant à s'assurer
que chacun de ses clients est bien en
conformité avec les services fiscaux de
son pays de résidence fin de citation
mais vous savez très bien que l'on
peut-être citoyen français résidant à
Genève possédant une société à jers et
titul d'un compte à Hong Kong les
montages permettent ce genre de
mécanisme aujourd'hui donc de quel
conformité de quel
pays prenez-vous compte pour vérifier la
con é de telle ou telle situation
ensuite un autre élément que je vais
citer le monde le journal Le Monde a
parlait d'une filiale de
Monaco relevant du Crédit Agricole qui
s'appelait le Crédit Foncier de Monaco
qui a demandé expressément à partir de
2010 au cabinet Monsac foseka de ne
jamais mentionner les noms complets des
bénéficiaires ou des sociétés qu'il
gérait pour son compte voilà ce que je
lis dans le monde est-ce que vous avez
un commentaire à faire sur cette sur
cette déclaration ensuite deux réactions
au propos que j'ai entendu en propos
liminire euh vous dites monsieur le
directeur que euh vous ne travaillez
uniquement qu'avec les pays qui
s'engagent à la transparence et à la
coopération mais effectivement le
monsieur le rapporteur général vient de
rappeler fort utilement l'audition
intéressante de Madame la procureur du
parquet national financier la semaine
dernière qui évoquait le cas de la
Suisse expressément où effectivement il
y avait relativement une bonne
coopération administrative mais quant au
Judici il y avait quelques réticences
pour ne pas dire plus notamment sur deux
dossiers qu'elle n'a pas cité bien
entendu mais qui montre bien la réalité
de cette situation enfin dernière chose
je crois que c'est monsieur auchochet
qui
évoque les activités immobilières
offshore et qui je vous cite dit a
priori il n'y a pas de difficulté
fiscale je suis un peu surpris de cette
expression a priori n'est-il pas dans
vos obligations réglementa de vérifier
qu'effectivement la situation fiscale
est tout à fait conforme voilà je vous
merci merci Éric beet vous voulez bien
répondre Monsieur le Directeur général
tout de suite à notre collègue oui je je
vais essayer madame la
Présidente j'essaie de prendre les les
éléments point par point effectivement
le le Crédit Agricole peut surprendre l'
qu'il est pointé sur ce type d'activité
je juste rappeler que les CL agricool
c'est la 10e Banque mondiale la 3è en
Europe nous sommes une banque universel
de 160000 collaborateurs de dizaines de
millions de clients et donc
effectivement nous fais on toutes les
activités d'une banque universelle dans
un monde qui est très globalisé avec des
risques mais aussi toutes les
obligations de contrôle qui sont
inhérentes à ces
risquesl vous avez cité des chiffres qui
que je ne valide pas un seul instant ce
n'était pas votre source mais sur
notamment la part de nos bénéfices vous
pouvez pas ignorer que le groupe cré
agricole travaille pour l'essentiel de
son PNB en France euh on ne peut pas
faire 2,4 milliards de résultats dans
des les paradis fiscaux quand on en fait
quatre ou CIN au total pour le groupe
cragricole en tout cas cela ne serait
pas compatible avec le fait d'avoir
versé 5 milliards d'euros d'impôts sur
les sociétés à l'état français sur les
derniers exercices je pense que au
rating des comment dire des
contributaires fiscaux en France nous
sommes extrêmement bien placés et je le
répète les activités qui sur lesquels
nous sommes auditionnés aujourd'hui
représente au plus en terme de chiffre
d'aff faire je parle de toute la Banque
Privée internationale pas du tout que
des structures offshore 2,4 % du PNB et
seulement 0,9 % pour le hors
Europe je voudrais également dire je
sais que ce n'est pas populaire et qu'au
fond j'affronte un a priori tout à fait
extérieur les structures offshore ce
n'est pas illicite et ce n'est pas
problématique par principe dès lors que
c'est transparent il y en a il y en aura
et il y a toujours des prestata TER y
compris des grandes banques qui vont
continuer à faire ce type d'activité ce
qui compte pour nous c'est que nous
soyons finalement et c'est un choix
volontaire car nous pourrions faire
autrement nous soyons strictement
opérant à l'intérieur des
territorialités des types de clientèle
qui sont de toute façon soumis à ce que
les politiques ont décidé c'est-à-dire
l'échange automatique d'information
quant aux informations fiscales euh
s'agissant de nos
implantations cela signifie que ce qui
compte pour nous pardonnez-moi de
prendre un terme anglais mais c'est le
booking c'est que au fond je prends un
client français qui est un a drroit sur
une structure au Panama en fait il est
français mais ce qui va compter c'est
que il est client d'un booking qui soit
est à Paris soit à Luxembourg soit à
Monaco soit en Suisse so Hong Kong qui
sont tous des pays échange automatique
d'information c'està-dire que ce qui
compte c'est qu'au fond là où le client
est chez nous nous soyons sur territoire
qui fasse partie de de ce ring d'échange
automatique d'information et les 11 pays
dans lequels nous avons du booking sont
tous de cette nature là ce qui me permet
de tenir de façon très ferme très
solennelle la politique que je viens de
citer il y a un instant s'agissant du
Crédit Foncier de
Monaco effectivement c'est une banque
qui appartient au Crédit Agricole par
par plaisir on est premier ou 2è mais
j'aime dire que c'est quasiment la
première banque mon Gasque c'est une
banque que nous avons acquis grâce à
l'acquisition
d'indosues je rappelle que Monaco est en
transparence fiscale depuis de très
nombreuses années avec la France c'estàd
qu'un Français qui va ouvrir un compte à
Monaco est automatiquement depuis très
longtemps déclaré à l'état français et
lorsque nous imposons comme dans tous
nos contrats à nos prestataires d'être
dans la confidentialité de nos clients
c'est pour protéger nos données protéger
nos clients et non pas nous soustraire
aux ayant droit officiels de lisibilité
sur nos comptes que sont les les
autorités et le
fisque voilà donc je par ailleurs vous
avez évoqué monsieur les sénateur
d'autres activités dans des pays qui
sont effectivement les pays dans lequel
ces activités s'opèent pour des raisons
industrielles ou au fond de
professionnalisme je crois que c'est une
erreur pardonnez-moi de vous le dire de
considérer que le pays s'associe
forcément à de l'opacité h le
financement des grandes structures
notamment de shipping ou d'éronautique
se font dans des pays dont le nom a une
connotation qui peut peut-être
surprendre mais qui se font en totale
transparence à la fois de rémunération
de fiscalité et juridique c'est le cas
du financement du shipping c'est le
financement aéronautique dans lequel le
créd agricole c'est vrai et nous en
sommes non seulement heureux mais fier
est un des grands leaders mondiaux des
financements de ce type d'activité
peut-être demander à Jean de préciser
sur ces autres types d'installation dans
ce type de pays prendre un ou deux
exemples pour montrer que au-delà des
mots par exemple les îles caiment ou
l'île de Man nous guernc nous avons des
activités qui sont liées au métier et
qui ne pose aucun problème de de
transparence vis-à-vis des autorités
monsieur merci bon ce qui est très
classique c'est l'organisation en
technique financière du financement des
avions et des bateaux donc si nous
prenons le cas des avions euh
généralement nous ne finançons pas la
compagnie aérienne euh nous finançons
l'avion lui-même donc l'avion va être
enveloppé dans une structure juridique
ad
hoc cette structure juridique est
l'emprunteur auprès de la banque ces
emprunts sont payés par les loyers payés
par la compagnie et l'argent perçu par
cette
structure et pour ce qui nous concerne
évidemment parfaitement connu du fil
Français au terme de l'article 219b du
Code Général des Impôts donc la raison
elle est purement je le disais tout à
l'heure de technique de financement
puisque pour le cas où la
compagnie en viendrait à ne pas payer
son loyer le crricole va saisir cet
avion et le revendre à une autre
compagnie ce qui d'ailleurs narrive
généralement pas puce que à la menace de
saisi de l'avion la compagnie paye sauf
si elle est vraiment en état de de
banquroute voilà donc ça ça se pratique
dans certains pays ou dans certains
États américains dont la juridiction
permet de le faire facilement notamment
au delware dans lequel il y a pas mal
d'immatriculation de société
aéronautique pour les bateaux il en est
de de même avec souvent deux grands
pavillons qui sont Panama î de Man euh
facil donc là encore le bateau va
être enveloppé dans une structure
juridique ad hoc c'est la structure qui
s'endette auprès de la banque les loyers
payés par l'armateur à cette société
pemprunt et si l'armateur avait des
difficultés à payer le le loyer sans
aucune formalité juridique la banque
peut se saisir du bateau et assez vite
le céd sur le marché mondial à un autre
euh armateur là encore pour les
armateurs français article 219b du code
général des impôts j'ai en tête deux
bateaux construits par un grand chantier
naval de l'Ouest de la France qui ont
été par qui par une grande société de
croisière française ils ont été
immatriculés au Panama ma connaissance
pour des raisons qui n'ont rien de de
fiscal on revient au question de
pavillon évoqué par madame la Présidente
tout à
l'heure merci François Marc va prendre
la parole ensuite André gatola
oui merci madame la Présidente euh
bonjour messieurs euh deux questions euh
qui ont trait au au sujet de
préoccupation naturelle de des autorités
publiques sur sur le sujet de l'offshore
puisque
l'ofshore peut-être jugé pernicieux dès
lors qu'il y a évasion fiscale ou s'il y
a blanchiment d'argent ce sont les deux
préoccupations principales
euh à cet égard euh s'agissant plus
particulièrement de l'évasion fiscale
euh bon au fil des auditions que réalise
la Commission on a le sentiment que
beaucoup d'arguments sont mis en avant
pour
légitimer les créations de comptes à
l'étranger et on a entendu encore ce
matin les euh principaux arguments sur
la gestion de l'immobilier le droit des
successions la domiciliation d'un Yach
d'un avion et cetera euh mais pourtant
lorsque cette affaire a été rendue
publique il y a quelques jours euh je
parler de Panama il a été dit dans la
presse que au fond 80
% des euh motivation que l'on pouvait
retenir relevait de l'évasion fiscale
autrement dit les quatre arguments
rationnels que vous évoquez pèseraient
si ces informations étaient justes pour
20%
alors que 80 % des motivations
reposeraient sur un désir d'évasion
fiscale donc je pense qu'il y a si ces
informations étaient vérifier sur les
chiffres un un sujet important à cet
égard et dès lors je voulais vous
interroger sur le renforcement récent de
vos contrôles et au fond est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus sur votre
programme dit de rectitude fiscale
est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire en
quoi ça ça consiste précisément et deuxè
question
relativement au contrôle et aux
vérifications à conduire justement pour
éviter qu'il n ait des sociétés ayant
des
pratiques sur du blanchiment ou autre
chose de plus
grave on sait qu'il y a des sociétés qui
refusaient de publier les documents
administratifs réglementaires ou des
états financiers annuels et que dès lors
il fallait aller se réfugier dans un un
compte pour permettre d'ouvrir les
comptes puisque ces sociétés refusaient
de répondre aux exigences locales donc
quels sont les vérifications auxquelles
on procède désormais avant de proposer
l'ouverture d'un
compte à ces sociétés et enfin dernière
chose puisque vous êtes devant une
commission
parlementaire on a le sentiment
que la législation française n'est pas
au point c'est pas au point sur droit
des successions puisqu'il faut aller
courir ailleurs pour trouver une réponse
c'est pas au point sur la gestion de
l'immobilier puisqu'il faut s'expatrier
pour être capable de gérer un
portefeuille immobilier c'est pas au
point sur la domiciliation d'un Yach ou
d'un avion parce que on est obligé
d'aller sur des comptes à l'étranger
donc qu'est-ce que vous nous suggérez
comme modification
législative à faire en France pour que
tout ça puisse être régler à domicile en
quelque sorte au lieu de mettre ses
sociétés en péril en ulté de leur
procurer des tracards les obligeant à
l'étranger est-ce qu'on peut pas
simplifier notre droit pour répondre à
toutes ces
exigences Monsieur le Directeur
Général sénateur donc sur le premier
pourcentage évidemment je suis incapable
de le valider donc il y a des médias qui
se sont prononcés je ne sais sur quelle
base sur le pourcentage de
motivation je voudrais également
souligner je ne l'aurais pas fait mais
je pense que ils sont mieux ils sont de
meilleur tiers de confiance que nous
mène que sur le site du consortium de
l'IJ qui a publié toutes ses bases il
est expressément écrit en anglais mais
je vais me tenter dans la traduction
française qu'il y a des raisons
légitimes de créer des compagnies
offshore dans deses juridictions et que
beaucoup de personnes sont parfaitement
en conformité fiscale là-dessus et donc
les déclaration de ce consortium mettent
bien en préambule que ces activités ne
sont pas illicites par principe loin en
fou et je le cite à la traduction prê
qu'il y a de nombreuses régions
légitimes pour que des personnes fassent
appel à ces juurridictions offshore sans
que cela soit finalement dérogatoire au
à la rectitude fiscale
voilà ce que je peux simplement
témoigner et au fond attester de notre
côté c'est que nous avons terminé le
travail de revérification fiscale
notamment des aant droits français et
dès lors qui savent parfaitement qu'ils
vont être dans l'échange automatique
d'information c'est la preuve sur
elle-même c'estàd que toutes ces
clientèles là je vous en cité en toute
transparence quand je prends le chiffre
maximum c'estàd quel que soit le
prestataire et quel que soit le
territoire sur ns 13000 clients français
de la Banque Privée internationale nous
avons aujourd'hui je vais pas dire
encore parce que c'est pas le bon mot
nous avons 23 structures offshore et
avec desendroits français ils le savent
ils le restent ce qui signifie que des
raisons légitimes que je ne peut pas
connaître ou que je je pourrais
connaître mais que on va pas détailler
cas par cas font que ces clients
considèrent qu'ils n'ont aucun problème
de s'être structuré de cette façon-là et
d'être soumis aux déclarations
automatiques vis-à-vis des différents
fisques et donc nous serions au tout
début d'une vérification fiscale nous
n'aurions pas le bénéfice du doute
là-dessus mais nous en avons terminé
nous avons des structures offshore qui
demeure le fait une nouvelle fois de
renoncer nous à être acteur de la
création c'est plus pour de la
lisibilité pour qu'il n'y ait aucun
doute sur le fait que nous ne sommes pas
générateurs de ce conseil làà et et pas
prestataire non plus ceci étant le fait
que nous ayons toujours en banque privée
des clientèles qui à travers ces
structures là vont être soumis aux
déclarations automatiques et au changes
automatiqu d'information et et la preuve
par la conscience des clients eux-mêmes
que ceci est en parfaite rectitude
fiscale sur la vérification des ayants
droit
euh on va y répondre sur les bien
monsieur le sénateur je pense sans
pouvoir l'attester de façon totalement
précise à la virgule près je pense que
la question vous que vous posez sur le
droit français n le problème c'est pas
directement ou seulement le droit
français on peut comprendre qu'une
personne est pas seulement française qui
achète ailleurs imaginez voilà un
espagnol qui achète à Hong Kong il va
essayer de trouver parce que c'est
licite le cadre J que et la formule
juridique qui lui est la plus convenable
en respectant toutes les réglementations
et donc dès lors que nous sommes dans ce
monde très globalisé dans lequel on
donne l'usage à tort ou à raison mais on
donne l'usage à nos clients ou à la
société au fond d'opérer dès lors que
cela respecte la réglementation et bien
on trouve effectivement des clientèles
qui optimisent leur situation au regard
de règles successorales au regard de
règles juridiques au regard de règles de
structuration je n'ai pas d'autes
inention que de venir témoigner devant
vous que s'agissant en tout cas du créd
agricole ceci ne s'opère que dans le
cadre d'une transparence et donc d'unun
d'un ring dans lequel l'échange
automatique d'information donnera aucune
opacité fiscal voilà et je je je ne
permets pas de formuler la moindre
recommandation sur l'évolution des
réglementations car au fond l'existence
de ces pays-là et et le résultat de leur
optimisation de réglementation pour être
attractif sur tel ou tel aspect
finalement de de besoins exprimés par
des clients sur lesendroit j'arrive
peut-être complétter bah sur sur les
aant droit il y a il y a finalement un
avant l'échange automatique et un
après dans l'avance ce que nous
demandons au client c'est une
attestation de ce qu'il est en
conformité avec le fils de son pays et
nous lui demandons donner son
identifiant fiscal la banque n'est pas
auto n'est pas habilité à exiger d'un
client qui nous donne sa déclaration
d'impôt on n pas les moyens juridiques
de de le faire ça c'est l'avant l'après
pour nous il est plus simple et nous
nous sommes extrêmement favorables on
l'avait dit devant vot votre commission
monsur l'année dernière c'est que la
transmission est automatique nous nous
donnons aux autorité fiscale du pays
dans lequel nous tenons les comptes
toutes les données et le reste sans
suite donc il y a il n'y a plus la
question de la sincérité du client qui
dit s'il est en confirmité ou pas cette
sincérité elle est inscrite dans le
processus je pense
pour répondre une partie de la question
vu de notre point de vue la partie
fiscal du sujet est résolu après il y a
des questions juridiques pourquoi
allons-nous dans certains pays parce que
le droit est plus souple mais c'est
encore une fois un débat qui n'est pas
nouveau qui est une nature un peu
différente ça ça ça c'est ce que dit la
presse nous nous n'avons pas
de comment
diraisirationur oui je je voudrais quand
même peut-être on peut lever un doute en
tout cas nous concernant voilà nous nous
nous avons toujours la même à peu près
taille de banque privée internationale
avant et après les vérifications la
Banque Privée international pour le
groupe réagcole c'est environ 70000
clients voilà nous et donc nous sommes
pas passés de 110000 à 3000 voilà nous
avons toujours 70000 clients en banque
privée internationale je vous ai donné
des des des des des réponses précises
sur les structures offshore et donc je
je n'ai lu de pas la possibilité le fait
qu'il y ait eu de la recherche d'évasion
fiscale dans le passé je dis simplement
que lorsque nous avons repassé toute la
clientèle française toute la
clientèleunion européenne et nous sommes
en train de finaliser le reste du monde
nous ne voyons pas notre activité
s'évaporer en tout cas de façon
significative et dès lors nous pouvions
considérer si je devais tenter centage
que l'essentiel des motivations de nos
clients n'était pas la recherche
d'évasion
fiscale merci André gatola oui merci
madame la Présidente bonjour Monsieur le
Directeur Général Monsieur le Directeur
Monsieur Brassac vous avez évoquer
effectivement le travail semble-t-il
considérable qui a été fait ces
dernières années pour l'extinction des
sociétés offshore et vous avez dit que
ça s'était fait par deux canaux soit
l'extinction pure et simple de la
société soit la session euh vous avez
évoqué notamment le cas de filiale vendu
à MWT donc ce groupe mauricien en disant
qu'il n'y avait évidemment une absence
de liens commerciaux j'imagine bien sûr
capitalistique entre des filiales du
Crédit Agricole et cette société moi ce
qui m'intéresserait de savoir c'est
est-ce qu'on peut en savoir d'avant plus
d'avantage sur ces sessions est-ce que
du personnel qui travaillait pour le
Crédit agricole ou une de ces filiales
en charge de ces comptes offchur ont été
transférés vers cette société repris par
cette société avec votre accord ou sans
votre accord est-ce que la nature des
des sessions qui ont été effectuées se
sont passées dans des condition je
dirais normale de marché de session
est-ce que quelles clauses ont été mises
en place et est-ce que vous avez une
vision de ce que deviennent les anciens
je dirais collaborateurs des filiales du
groupe du crédit agricolees qui se sont
retrouvés dans des sociétés de ce enfin
vendu ou arrêté qu'est-ce qu'elles sont
devenues ou est-ce qu'elles sont passé
je vous
remercie monsieur le sénateur alors
d'abord je pense pas qu'il y a de
confusion mais je préfère êre très
explicite nous n'avons jamais affiché
que nous voulions mettre en extinction
le nombre de structures offshore par
principe elles sont licites elles
peuvent être utiles nous affirmons
simplement que lorsqu'il y en a nous
devons opérer dans un cadre qui permet
la transparence fiscale ce que nous
avons décidé c'est l'arrêt d'être
prestataire nous-mêmes conseil
intermédiaire créateur gestionnaire de
ces structures offshore je vais répondre
à vos questions j'espère le faire le
plus précisément possible mais je me
rends compte à l'instant qu'en voul en
faire plus loyal que la réglementation
je m'attire sur moi-même une sorte de
soupçon ce sont des activités
parfaitement légales une nouvelle fois
que d'autres vont continuer à faire et
je pourrais très bien défendre de votre
votre commission que nous avons gardé
ces activités
comme d'autres banques le font que nous
avons ou alors que nous sommes en
partenariat que nous y avions mis du
capital ou que nous sommes en lien
d'affaair nous avons pris cette décision
parce que j'estime que sur le plan de la
réputation pour le groupe CR agricole
dans un sujet qui est très vaste et qui
est très complexe pour la lisibilité ce
que je disais en terme de politique
générale nous ne pouvons plus nous
contenter de strictement respecter les
réglementations de chaque pays nous
devons donner une politique qui soit
très lisible sans ambigué pour tous ceux
qui nous observent et pour une grande
banque comme le cladi agricole la
réputation est une valeur essentielle
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
décidé d'arrêter ce type de prestation
et de ne pas être comment dire reproché
non pas accusé mais reproché d'être à la
génèse du conseil pour structurer les
patrimoines de cette façon-là pour être
plus précis maintenant sur votre
question par par deux structures nous
nous sommes mis en extinction tout court
c'estàdire que au fond euh au Luxembourg
notamment euh nous pratiquions euh ce
conseil et cette structuration offshore
que nous ne faisons plus tout cours il
n'y a pas de session nous avons arrêté
l'activité et s'agissant notamment de
créd récolle Suisse conseil que nous
avons cédé pour le coup en toute
transparence à une structure qui est
parfaitement connue nous n'avons passé
aucun accord commercial par contre
vendre une structure c'est évidemment
entre Guillemé pardonnez-moi
l'expression vendre les collaborateurs
avec sinon il n'y aurait pas bon et et
je rajoute pourê très alors nous n'avons
pas de capital nous n'avons pas de liens
commerciaux mais nous avons mis une
détachement d'une personne pour être
très précis euh pour au fond surveiller
la transition et faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas de difficulté par rapport à
nos clientèles et donc de façon très
concrète nous avons un détachement pour
deux ou trois années d'une personne qui
est en fait là pour vérifier que ce que
nous avons décidé de faire s'opère de
façon convenable tu avais des précisions
à apporter j'enrive euh non je voulais
simplement confirmer ce que tu dis c'est
comme dans toute session l'acheteur
achète la société et et les employés
généralement sont transférés en toute
partie chez chez nouvel acheteur voilà
tout oui pardon on me souffle à l'estant
je précise quand je dis qu'il n'y a pas
de lien commercial encore moins des
commissions d'apport je je
voilà mais cette comment dire cette idée
que nous pourrions simplement mettre à
côté de façon moy visible cette activité
n'est pas rationnel parce qu'au fond si
nous voulions faire à ça nous pouvions
garder la structure elle-même et et et
affronter au fond l'explication comme
d'autres la donnent aujourd'hui en
disant que ce qui compte au fond c'est
la c'est la transparence fiscale nous
sommes nous allons plus loin que les
contraintes en abandonnant ce type
d'activité parce que cette activité à
tort ou raison de façon rationnelle ou
pas crée un problème de réputation pour
les banques qui
opèrent merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur Général voilà pour cette
audition dans le cadre des travaux de la
commission des finances qui cherche à
évaluer le chemin parcouru pour lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale et qui reste
visiblement à parcourir place à présent
à l'audition de la BNP pariba qui s'est
déroulé le même jour et sur le même
thème précision tout de même la BNP
avait déjà été auditionnée en 2012 dans
le cadre de la commission d'enquête sur
le rôle des banques dans l'évasion
fiscale à l'époque Baudoin pro était
alors PDG de la BNP pariba et il avait
déclaré qu'il voulait retirer toutes ses
activités du Panama en 2009 mais qu'il
avait été dissuadé par le qu d'orset
depuis vous le savez la banque a été
elle aussi mise en cause dans le
scandale des Panama papers tout de suite
donc retour à l'audition de BNP pariba
je vous remerci de Don l'occasion de
nous exprimer dans ce dans ce forum sur
ce sujet important et de vous informer
des actions du groupe euh dans le
domaine de la lutte contre la la fraude
fiscale alors depuis enfin dès 2009 et
la transposition la 3e directive euh qui
intégrit la frutete fiscale comme dans
le cadre régissant la la la lutte contre
le blanchiment notre groupe a initié un
programme très important très rigoureux
de renforcement de nos modes de de
commercialisation et de contrôle au
niveau de la Banque Privée
internationale alors dans le cadre de ce
programme quatre décisions structurantes
ont été pris que je voudrais vous
énumérer puis je rentai un petit peu
plus en détail ensuite dans dans chacune
chacune d'elles dans ces cas décision
sont sont les sont les suivantes
premièrement le renforcement continu de
notre dispositif de connaissance de
clients le K ici new your customer euh
désolé de l'anglicisme c'est vraiment le
terme qui est qui est communement
utilisé pour pour cette pour cet
exercice deuxièmement l'arrêt de nos
activités liées à l'administration pour
nos clients de sociétés
offshore la demande systématique euh de
déclaration de conformité fiscale auprès
de tous nos clients résidentss français
Union européenne et au CDE depuis 2013
et enfin aussi depuis 2013 nous
n'ouvrons plus de comptes
au nom de société offshore pour des
bénéficiaires économiques finaux
résidents fiscaux
français alors je vais maintenant donner
peut-être rentrer un petit peu dans le
dans le concret de chacune de ces de ces
mesures pour donner une une bonne idée
de ce ce dont il s'agit alors dès 2009
nous avons entrepris un programme donc
très conséquent de renforcement de notre
processus de de KYC qui vise à à nous
assurer de la bonne connaissance de de
nos clients toute nouvelle entrée en
relation que dans le monde où que ce
soit dans le monde est validée par un
comité d'acceptation client un comité
qui se tient en commun entre les équipes
de la banque privée et les équipes de la
conformité la fonction conformité au
sein du groupe NP parba est une fonction
indépendante indépendante des métiers
intégrée globalement dont le responsable
don global est ici présent Éric Martin
Éric Martin reporte directement à
jean-laur on a fait notre directeur
général ça représente combien de de
personnes cette ce comité la conformité
oui
aujourd'hui 2700 2700 on vient de 1700 à
peu près à la fin
2014 pardon nous venons donc d'à peu
près 1700 la question c'était combien de
personnees sur cette 1700 à la fin 2014
à peu près 2700 à la fin 2015 avec un
objectif d'être proche de 3500 à la fin
de cette
année
merci dans dans ces comités
d'acceptation clients le la direction de
la conformité a un droit de véau final
sur à la fois l'entrée en relation ou ou
le la continuation d'une relation avec
avec nos
clients donc dans ces comités il s'agit
de de comprendre parfaitement qui sont
nos futurs clients ou N ou nos clients
leur motivation l'origine des fonds euh
la transparence des flux qui vont
transiter sur sur sur nos comptes ainsi
que le type de gestion qui est adapté à
notre à notre client alors ce filtre
s'inscrit naturellement dans le cadre
général de la lutte contre le
blanchiment contre la fraude fiscal
contre la corruption le financement du
terrorisme ainsi que bien sûr tes les
sanctions le respect des sanction
internationales actuellement en
vigueur alors dans le cas d'utilisation
de structure
offshore personne morale j'aur
l'occasion de revenir sur sur ce que
l'on entend che par structure
offshoreev tout à l'heure dans le cas
d'utilisation de structure offshore les
bénéficiaires économiques sont toujours
connus c'est sur le bénéficiire
économique que se fait le KYC et non pas
sur la structure c'estous souitons
connaître le béf économique
final donc nous analysons dans ce cas le
bcque final et puis la raison d'être de
cette structure pourquoi utiliser une
structure dans dans le cas qui nous qui
nous intéresse à chaqueité d'acation
client si le bénéficiaire économique
final ne peut être identifié ou validé à
ce momentl re relation ne se fait pas
donc on peut pas on peut pas pas parler
de société écran puisque nous regardons
à travers la société qui est le
bénéficiaire économique ultime de cette
de cette
société tous les font l'objet d'un un
score de risque multiritère qui est le
même mondialement qui détermine le
niveau de risque d'une relation et la
fréquence de revue de cette relation
dans notre jargon c'est le score mlra
c'est notre jargon
interne les transactions réalisées sur
les comptes font également l'objet de de
filtre systématique pour en assurer la
la
conformité et je je précise que ce
dispositif donc est un dispositif qui
est en place dans toutes nos
implantations de B privé international
est revue non seulement par notre
inspection interne mais aussi par tous
les régulateurs qui nous qui nous
surveillent dans tous les pays nous
opérons et encore récemment mondialement
par par la
CPR donc ça c'est pour le la première
partie qui est la le le New York
customer 2è en 2è lieu depuis 2010 nous
avons entamé un processus de session de
nos activités lié à l'administration de
sociétés offshore euh les liens avec
société ont été stoppés dès la session
de ces sociétés et qui exercent depuis
le leur activité en propre c'est-à-dire
de manière indépendante par rapport à
notre groupe alors là il y a eu un
certain nombre de sessions je va juste
les énumérer pour vous vous donner une
idée de la de de l'ampleur de de
l'exercice en 2010 nous avons vendu BP
par Bahamas limited à banque of
noascochia une banque canadienne la
société a ensuite été enfin nous av
vendu le le le le fond de commerce à
l'activité àancoch n gardé la
structurgie qui ensuite été été liquidé
en 2013 la succursale de benp pariba Wal
management à Panama a également été
vendu en 2010 à la banque noascosia la
même banque banque canadienne et la
structure juridique benp management
Panama a été liquidé en
2012 BNP paribba Trust Company à Genève
a été cédé en 2010 au groupe watamar et
a été ensuite renommé par ce groupe
candeo corporate serviceuse
FUP part au Luxembourg a été cédé en
2014 un cabinet d'expertise locale
comptable locale et puis la dernière ben
trust BV au Pays-Bas a été cédé au début
de cette année un cabinet là aussi
d'expertise comptable
local toutes ces sociétés ont donc été
été été cédé
aujourd'hui n'exerce pas de d'activités
d'administration de sociétés offshore
pour le compte de ses
clients
al en 3è 3è point 3è décision importante
depuis 2013 nous
avons renforcer notre dispositif de
spécifiquement contre la fraude fiscale
deux choses làdessus tout d'abord pour
tous nos clients résidents de la France
l'Union européenne en général et
l'OCDE nous
demandons systématiquement à tous nos
clients une déclaration de conformité
fiscale euh une fois ces déclaration de
conformité fiscale obtenu de nos
clients leur
fiabilité je je vous inter une minute
pour tous vos clients nouveaux ou pour
tous ceux qui qui sont déjà là c'estàd
tous ceux qui étent là le stock tous
tous les clients en compte chez nous
clients résidents fiscaux de la France
de l'Union européenne ou de et de l'OCDE
ce grand ensemble de 50 pays tous les
clients résidents fiscaux de ces pays
ont dû nous renvoyer une déclaration de
conformité fiscale nous avons envoyé
30000 letett 30000
lettres alors ces déclaration étant
faite ou pas faite jeadresse ce ce qui
se passe alors qu'elle n pas lorsque
nous ne recevons pas cette cette
déclaration lorsque nous recevons cette
déclaration de conformité fiscale nous
en validons nousons en valider la
fiabilité ceci est fait avec nos équipes
de conformité et équipes juridique du
groupe et les équipes équipe de la
Banque Privée bien sûr mais surtout avec
les équipes de conformité dire en
valider la
et nous faisons ça à l'aide d'un certain
nombre de de critères de conformité
fiscale que nous av mis au point
typiquement lorsqu'il y a des flux
réguliers entre le compte offshore et et
le compte du client dans son pays
d'origine c'est un facteur rassurant
lorsqu'il n'y a jamais de mouvement
c'est un facteur aggravant donc il y a
toute une série d'indicateurs qui mis en
place et lorsque même lorsque nous avons
reçu une déclaration de conformité
fiscale s'il y a des facteurs aggravants
en quantité he à ce momentlà nous
l'acceptons pas nous ne la validons pas
alors que se passe-t-il lorsque nous ne
recevons pas pour vous les facteurs
aggravant c'est donnez-nous deux trois
exemples c'est pas celui-là pas du tout
de pas de lien un client qui est
difficilement joignable un client qui ne
se connecte jamais à son compte sur nos
sites Internet pour savoir quelle est la
l'évolution du compte typiquement voilà
le genre de le genre de chose donc un
client qui a tout le comportement
lorsquil a pas mal de mouvement en cash
sur le compte en
liquide tout ça sont des des des indices
de suspicion je dirais de nonconformité
donc lorsque nous nous recevons une
déclaration de coné fiscal mais il y a
existence d'un certain nombre de ces
facteurs aggravants nous ne la validons
pas alors que se passe-t-il maintenant
lorsqueil n'ont pas reçu déclaration ou
lorsqu'elle n'est pas validée B là il y
a deux choses le compte est bloqué donc
le client n'a plus accès à à ces fonds
puisque nous avons qui une sorte de de
certitude interne comme quoi une
conviction comme quoi le client n'est
pas conforme fiscalement donc le compte
est bloqué euh et ensuite il se peut a
plus que deux options
soit le le client n demande de rapatrier
l'argent dans son pays de de résidence
fiscale et donc là il se se il se voilà
il est il est il est vu dans son pays
d'origine de résistence
fiscale à propos lorsque si cet argent
venait chez BNP parib
en France par exemple nous devrions
faire une déclaration auprès de
tracf voilà soit le le client bah nous
l'accompagnons pour auprès des autorités
fiscales de son P de résidence pour
qu'il se dé pour régulariser sa
situation et en attend de régularisation
le compte est est donc est donc bloqué
j'ai une première question et puis
ensuite le rapporteur général et nos
collègues qui vont
s'inscrire je je je vouse une question
sur euh vous nous avez dit que vous avez
mis fairex
activités service fiduciaire à la
gestion à l'ouverture à la gestion de
société écran mais vous n'avez pas bien
évidemment externalisé tout cela euh
pour sortir du bilan de la banque et et
et garder garder des offres à vos
clients c'est c'est ma question en effet
selon le monde fin 2010 la BNP aurait
avait cédé au cabinet luxembourgeois
vatamar et compagnie sa fiduur Suisse
BNP trust compagnie sa qui comptait 6
sociétés offshore Activ et cette
dernière avait été rebaptisée Cando
corporate service toutefois selon les
déclarations du directeur de candéo
Patrick taverne d'après le monde
toujours candéo continue à travailler
principalement pour BNP pour des raisons
de relation interpersonnelle donc ces
deux activités ont été réellement
scindées gardez-vous vous des liens avec
cette ancienne filiale qu'il soit
capitaliski ou d'une autre nature y
compris informelle
d'ailleurs avez-vous des relations avec
les clients de cand au corporate service
quand il s'agit de client que vous aviez
redirigé vers l'option autre
fois voilà et vous avez dit que vous ne
mettez plus en en
place de société écran directement ou
indirectement via une filiale ou un
partenaire
euh et vous dites n vous n'ouvrez plus
de comptte pour les sociétés offshore
dont le bénéficiaire est un résident
fiscal français
final pourquoi avoir décidé de mettre
fin à cette activité et quelle
alternative proposez-vous à ceux qui
auraient des motifs à vos yeux légitimes
et et est-ce qu'éventuellement vous vous
pourriez nous
dire ce qu'il faudrait faire pour que
des véhicules français suffisamment
souple permettent d'atteindre les mêmes
buts puisqueau fond la commission des
finances est à la recherche de de cela
il y a-t-il il y a des v on parle de
frein et dans ce contexte est-ce que
vous auriez une idée de ce qu'il
faudrait faire alors je je réponde aux
différentes questions vous plusieurs
plusieurs questions
sur la la la session de notre filiale
benp parba trus compagnie à Genève donc
comme je l'ai indiqué comme vous le
rappelez elle a eu lieu en 2010 elle a
été cédé donc à ce cabinet à cette
société watama
et depuis renommé candoop tout ceci est
exact euh je n'ai pas utilisé le terme
externalisation j'ai le terme cession
nous avons vendu cette filiale à à
watama donc depuis cette date cette
société Cando corporate serviceus donc
le nouveau nom de notre filiale bah
conduit ses activités en propre
euh sans indépendamment
de de BNP parib euh nous n'avons euh pas
d'élément euh concernant d'éventuels
lien à titre personnel entre des des
collaborateurs benpareba et des
collaborateurs Cando il n'y a pas de
politique de traité avec candéo il n'y a
pas d'accord commercial avec CEO et
d'ailleurs comme nous n'ouvrons plus de
structure au nom de clients français
depuis 2013 il n'y aurait même pas de
raison d'en avoir je voilà donc euh
voilà pour pour pour euh
la la
relation il n'y en a pas entre il a pas
de relation commerciale entre benp par
et bain et cand aujourd'hui et ni depuis
la vente alors sur POS la question de
savoir qu quel serait les les les les
améliorations à apporter pour que les
clients français n'ai pas besoin d'avoir
recours à des structures dans les pays
alors je crois que pour répondre à cette
question il faut se il faut voir que
l'utilisation de structures offshore euh
do doit s'apprécier un petit peu dans le
fin en fonction de de l'environnement
juridique vois successorale euh fiscal
de différents pays dansquel nous nous
nous opérons tout n'est pas pareil et
tous les pays du monde n'ont pas n'ont
pas à leur disposition un cadre
juridique stable un un environnement
doit successoral aussi clair défini
celui que nous connaissons en France et
donc ce qui est vrai pour la France
n'est pas forcément vrai pour pour
d'autres pays je pense et notamment les
pays hors OCDE Asie en particulier
fonctionne de manière assez différente
donc il faut fa vraiment regarder les
pays par pays pour ce qui concerne la
France bah nous nous considérons qu'il
existe en
France les outils juridiques nécessaires
pour la gestion la structuration et la
transmission de patrimoine à disposition
aujourd'hui en France
donc nous voyons pas aujourd'hui pour un
résident fiscal français de nécessité
absolu d'aller chercher une structure
offshore c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle depuis
2013 nous avons décidé que nousons plus
de
compte de de ce parce que nous voyons
nous ne voyons pas la
nécessité donc je voilà merci beaucoup
monsieur le rapporteur général je
voudrais je voudrais juste préciser sur
ce point chose c'est qu'à nouveau le le
ceci est vrai pour la France euh nous
allons pour notamment pour les pays hors
OCDE Asie en particulier nous allons
faire une analyse dans les mois qui
viennent et tu peux cas par cas pays par
pays de la situation l'environnement
juridique environnement fiscal et loi
successoral pour définir une notre
politique à l'avenir sur sur les pays
Hocde mais là on est on est assez loin
de notre périmètre qui nous concerne
aujourd'hui qui qui est spécifiquement
la France c'est important de préciser
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Directeur
monsieur le rapporteur général merci
présente merci monieur alors voilà je
lis le le bultin quotidien qui est
toujours très intéressant et là qui
parle aujourd'hui BNP paribba n'a plus
de filiale aux î caillement et possède
encore de surcursales actives
et donc l'information c'est que vous
avez confirmé hier la fermeture de
filial au caillement mais vousz encore
deux succursales donc qui serait BNP
paribba sa et une banque de détail ban
of West et une étité qui s'appelle
marque finance alors pourquoi cette
antivité Marc finance n'est pas
comptabilisé dans le périmètre du groupe
et sa première question est quelle est
l'activité de ces de ces filiales au
caillement parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
Panama mais g peut-être sintéresse au
caillement voilà c'est prière question
la deuxème question sera la même que vos
prédécesseur d'une autre
banque quelle serait l'attitude de de la
banque si un client vous demandait de
participer à une
opération dont la finalité serait
exclusivement fiscale donc concrètement
on n pas
donc quiait est-ce que voilà quelle
serait
l'attitude si vous proposez un montage
c'est un client régulier donc quelle
serattitude et la deème question vous
avez évoqué à l'instant le fait que vous
recherchez l'identité réelle de de
bénéficiaire de de Trust par
exemple ce qui nous étonne un peu c'est
qu'on a entendu la semaine dernière
madame Moulette la procureur de du PNF
qui nous a dit que malgré tous les
toutes les textes les accords en matière
de coopération judiciaire très sou
souvant il était extrêmement difficile
voire impossible pour le PNF de
connaître l'identité des bénéficiaires
effectif de Trust et ça rejoint un peu
les propos de la DG FIP qui nous a
également confirmé toutes les
difficultés qu'elle avait en matière de
coopération fiscale internationale
pourre l'identité des trust alors
pourquoi une banque pourrait connaître
l'identité réelle des bénéficiires de
Trust dire une base volontaire sinon
vous fermez les comptes des clients
alors même que l'administration fiscale
ou le le le parquet national financier
n'y arriverait pas et dans ce cas-là si
vous connaissez l'identités réelle des
bénéficiires de Trust est-ce que vous
transmettez cette
information vous vous avez parlé du know
your customer tout à l'heure donc vous
êtes censé connaître vos clients est-ce
qu'il y a une coopération notamment ave
l'administration fiscale française pour
transmettre s information merci bien sû
je vais alors
je trois questions une question sur
caillementqu je vous répondre tout de
suite une question sur que faisons-nous
en cas d'opération à finalité purement
fiscale je laisserai Christian com
principalement fiscal principalement
fiscal nous avons un code de conduite
lourrence est très claire donc nous
allons pouvoir vous répondre assez
facilement et puis je reprend la parole
pour pour la partie trust alors sur sur
lescaillement les les articles récemment
parus dans la dans la presse sont sont
exactes au
sens l' soulligne le fait que notre
groupe a réduit très fort ement le
nombre d'implantation au caïment depuis
un certain nombreu un certain nombre
d'années à aujourd'hui il est exact nous
n'avons aujourd'hui que deux entités au
Caan au î Caillan qui sont les deux
succursales comme vous le soullignez
l'une de benp pariba sa et l'autre de
Bank of the West sa ban of West je
rappelle est notre filiale de banque de
retail aux
États-Unis alors que ce même nombre de
deux était de 10 en 2012 et de 6 en 2014
vous voyez la la réduction a été
considérable au cours des au cours des
des dernières années je précise
d'ailleurs com information
supplémentaire que la succursale bank of
the West inactive et en cours de
clôture alors le le marc finance posé
une question spécifiquement sur Marc
finance Marc finance c'est une société
qui est déconsolidée parce que elle est
elle est trop petite pour être c'est une
filiale
euh qui existe mais qui est déconsolé
par que elle est trop petite pour faire
en dessous des seuils de de de
consolidation quelle
activité Marc finance c'est
une c'est pas lié à François Mar non
c'est pas lié à François Mar non non
c'est je
je je vous donne
l'formation on le mettra dans le
questionnaire euh mais c'est qui qui est
qui qui est devenue qui est toute petite
et donc en dessous des se en dessous des
sees de consolidation donc n'est pas
n'est plus consolidé
euh quand on parle de caillement il faut
même souligner que pour toutes nos
activités enfin les deux les deux
succursales que qui opère au caillement
nous sommes fiscalisés aux États-Unis
donc il n'y a pas ni objectif ni ni
effet d'optimisation fiscale pour BNP
Paribas du fait de ces deux de ces deux
succursales au caillement euh et puis
aussi rappeler quand même que bah le le
les caillements euh sont une juridiction
qui a après un examen par le par le
Forum mondial leocde en 2013 approfondi
de leur structure juridique procédure et
cetera euh à s'est vu euh considéré
comme étant conforme par le Forum
mondial de l'OCDE euh et puis par
ailleurs les caillements sont c'est
c'est une des juridictions qui s'est
engagé à l'échange automatique ination
dès 2017 fait dès la fin de cette année
préciser le cadre le cadre de de de
fonctionnement de de cette
juridiction je passe la réponse
oui oui sur les sur lescaillements
d'ailleurs on peut ajouter que le
l'écaillement pratique avec la France de
l'échange automatique d'information
depuis 2005 c'est quelque chose qui est
un petit peu perdu de vue mais dans le
cadre de la directive épargne en fait
les les les les caillements échange
échange de de l'information de manière
automatique avec avec la France alors
pour revenir à la question sur le sur
les opérations à but exclusivement
fiscal là il faut il faut être tout à
fait clair
principalement le le le le le le groupe
BNP Paribas ne ne s'engage ni pour
lui-même ni pour ni pour ses clients
dans dans dans des opérations qui
n'auraient pas autre finalité que que
que fiscale
le nous avons en la matière une une
pratique tout à fait tout à fait clair
et et des codes de conduite tout à fait
clair c'est d'une part le respect le
respect de la loi bien sûr dans les
différents pays dans lesquels nous
sommes
implantés mais c'est c'est aussi une
analyse de chaque de chaque opération en
allant au-delà de sa simple validité
juridique on s'assure que chaque
opération a bien une finalité
économique et on a je dirais en la
matière une
approche qui qui qui s'apparente à du à
du plus 10 ans c'est-à-dire que nous
nous avons tendance y compris dans des
pays qui n'ont pas forcément un un
appareillage aussi sophistiqué que la
France en matière de lutte contre les
abus nous avons tendance à apprécier les
opértion
à l'ône de l'AB de l'abus de droit à la
française donc que ce soit pour le
groupe BNP ou pour ses clients nous nous
veillons à ce que les opérations n'ai
pas une une finalité fiscale mais bien
une finalité
économique raorteur
général je sur sur sur les trus c'est
c'est une question qui revient qui
revient régulièrement je pense que c'est
c'est important dans
la difficulté qu' équ le PNF et alors je
je pense que quand on parle
trust un petit peu ce que c'est qu'un
trust trust n'est pas la même chose
qu'une société offshore ça c'est ilut
qu'on soit peu comprendre ce que c'est
qu'un trust le Trust est un
un un outil juridique qui est reconnu
par la loi la commun britannique c'est
quel chose qui qui est commun dans la
commun low britannique et donc un outil
qui est utilisé de manière assez
courante par
nos amis britanniques pour la gestion de
leur patrimoine ou de leur succession et
Amérique britannique et dans le monde
les différentes juridictions diffents
pays qui utilisent la communau
Britannique notamment l'Asie et le trust
c'est un outil qui est très communément
utilisé par par les clients
asiatiques benp pariba aujourd'hui a
deux sociétés de Trust he de gestion de
Trust
en existence une à Jersey et l'autre à
Singapour jerse Trust Company Singapour
Trust Company je précise qu'au sein de
ces deux sociétés nous gérant aucun
trust pour des résidents fiscaux
français mais ces deux sociétés existent
90 % des trusts que nous gérons sont
pour des asiatiques donc ça ça voilà ça
donne une idée de la de la de
la là où ça se passe le trust c'est quoi
c'est un un donc un une enveloppe de
gestion et de transmission c'est le par
rapport à ce que nous connaissons ici en
France c'est ce qui se rapproche le plus
de l'assurance vie en réalité donc c'est
un une enveloppe de gestion d'un
patrimoine avec des clauses
bénéficiaires c'est
assez un peu différent mais c'est le
plus proche trouver c'est c'est
l'assurance vie pour donner une image de
ce que de comment cela
fonctionne alors le droit français ne
reconnaît pas le
trust en revanche le trust les trust ont
fait l'objet d'une attention par le
législateur français euh qui a instauré
une obligation de déclaration auprès du
trusty donc la société de gestion du
trust de trusty doit déclarer le trust
aux autorités françaises dès lors que
euh l'un des bénéficiaires et résident
français ou l'un des biens
euh détenu par le Trust est situé sur le
sol français donc obligation de de de
déclaration le législur a aussi prévu
que bah le bénéficiaire du trust serait
taxé en France à l'ISF ou toute autre
taxation donation succession au même
titre qu'un résident fiscal français
vous posez la question de savoir comment
est-ce que l'administration fiscale euh
enfin si les tous les Gires de Trust
font leur travail tel que c'est demandé
par la loi française c'est déclaré pour
ce qui n concne n n'en gérons pas pour
des Français donc quelque part pas
concerné par cette par cette situation
euh
le qu' g pas pour pour pour des pour des
clients
français mais si il y a déclaration à ce
momentl le Trust est totalement
transparent et quelque part il n'y a pas
d'intérêt pour un résident fiscal
français d'utiliser un trust comme
enveloppe pour gérer ses
actifs parce que c'est totalement
transparent voilà j'espère avoir été un
peu clair sur le alors une société
offshore peut-être une société qui
quelque part détenu par le trust on en
revient mais c'est vraiment une
enveloppe de gestion le trust ce n
rienutre qu' qu'un engagement de gérer
un patrimoine pour le compte d'un client
dans certaines règles et avec certaines
clauses de successoral ou de clauses
bénéficiire d'ailleurs qui sont
succession ou pas de succession parfois
des trust peuvent c'est la différence
l'assurance VI l'assurance vie déverse
en cas de décès du détenteur de la
police le trust peut se libérer sur des
enfants par exemple dans certaines
conditions et pas forcément en cas de
décès pas uniquement en cas de décès de
la personne détenteur du trust
constituant du
trust merci je peux demander une
précision monsieur Comolet Timan vous
avez répondu sur le fait que la question
était l'exclusivement fiscal vous vous
avez le même propos si c'est
partiellement
fiscal donc nous comme je le disais on
se on on se cale sur cequel sur l'abus
de droit sur l'abus de droit la à la à
la française euh donc les les les
opérations à finalité à finalité
fiscale nous nous ne nous ne les nous ne
les pratiquons pas après dans toute
opération le le la charge fiscale est un
élément de coût à prendre en compte
comme comm comme tout autre comme toute
autre charge donc le le le le coût
fiscal le coût fiscal d'une opération
est est pris en compte dans
l'appréciation de la rentabilité globale
d'une opération mais en aucun cas le le
l'objet de l'opération doit être doit
être de de de d'éviter d'éviter un impôt
qui serait qui serait normalement dû
merci euh Éric boet est inscrit il sera
suivi de François
Marc bien merci madame la Présidente
bonjour messieurs Monsieur le Directeur
donc vous avez évoqué les dernières
années pour décrire les évolutions de
votre établissement en matière de
gestion de société offshore notamment
mais moi je voudrais revenir à
l'audition de Monsieur budu impr pro en
son temps le 17 avril 2012 qui avait été
entendu par la commission
d'enquête relative au sujet de l'évasion
fiscale et également au propos de
Monsieur
pbot le 9 juillet 2013 alors c'était une
audition celle-là à hclos mais j'en ai
pris des notes assez pr précise j'en ai
un souvenir assez précis donc je vais
m'y référer pour vous interroger sur
certains aspects qui viennent d'être
évoqués donc monsieur pro avait déclaré
en 2012 que rien dans l'activité de
notre groupe ne conduit à l'évasion
fiscale et vous venez de nous dire là
que depuis 2013 on n'ouvre plus de
comptes offshore donc là il y a un petit
décalage qui qui m'interpelle
évidemment le les révélations de
l'opération Panama papers à laquelle on
se réfère depuis le début de ces
auditions mentionne le chiffre de 400 68
sociétés offshore depuis les années 80
géré et créé par votre établissement à
partir du cabinet mossac Fonseca que
tout le monde connaît
aujourd'hui en 2010 effectivement vous
gériez 4207 trustes à Hong Kong et
Singapour vous venez de confirmé que
c'était essentiellement pour une
clientèle asiatique c'est localisation
le
confirme j'ai pour ma part en ma
possession des documents interne qui
montre par le menu et le détail les
explications relatives à la CRÉ et la
gestion de Trust donc là aussi il y a
une contradiction qui qui m'interpelle
et sur laquelle j'aimerais que vous vous
exprimiez euh monsieur pébro je me
souviens avait cité également en 2013 la
présence de de filial de la BNP parib
bas sur deux territoires précis le
sultanat de Bruneï et les Philippines
qui à l'époque figuraiit déjà sur la
liste des territoires non coopératifs
les ETNC donc là aussi il y a un
éclaircissement sans doute à apporter je
vrais ensuite évoquer le l'amende que
les autorités américaines ont infligé à
votre établissement l'an dernier je
crois fin 2015 de près de 9 milliards de
dollars me semble-t-il est-ce que donc
c'est relatif à des activités euh avec
des pays sous embargot américains trois
ou quatre d'entre eux euh est-ce que ces
activités auraient pu être menées à
partir de sociétés offshore à partir de
certains territoires figurant sur la
liste au CDE par exemple des paradis
fiscaux euh et par ailleurs est-ce que
cette cette amende a pu être comment
dirais-je figuré en perte fiscale pour
votre établissement par rapport au fisqu
français ensuite on vient d'évoquer
effectivement nous avons appris hier par
une dépêche de l'agence Reuters que vous
aviez fermé vos filiales au
caïon alors les caillans qui sont un
territoire quand même très très
particulier même si depuis 2005 il nous
ait dit que la coopération semble
fonctionner rappelons quand même qu'il y
a un immeuble à Georgetown la capitale
des î caimo qui s'appelle GL House qui
est le siège de 12748 entreprises c'est
un immeuble de 5 étages je précise donc
il y a effectivement quelques raisons de
s'inquiété de cette situation et donc ça
c'était largement après 2005 alors
quelles activités meniez-vous dans ces
filiale au caïent et pour quelle raison
avez-vous décidé de quitter ce
territoire au moins en partie merci
merci Monsieur le
Directeur alors ça fait ça fait beaucoup
de questions alors je vais essayer de de
d'y répondre le plus précisément
possible sur sur les propos de Baudoin
pro devant cette commission en 2012 moi
je ne vois rien qui affirme ce que vous
a dit Bono
pro nous avons enfin rien en 2012
ne dans l'activité de benp pariba était
une incitation à l'évasion fiscale les
mesures que nous avons prises que je
vous ai décrit tout à l'heure en grand
détail sur notre politique interne date
de avant avant 2012 puisque nous avons
commencé notre programme en 2010 en
différentes étapes et renforcé
progressivement et effectivement une des
une des étapes a été que depuis 2013
nousons plus de structure offshore pour
des clients résidents fiscaux français
mais avant 2013 benp pariba avait déjà
une attitude totalement responsable en
la en la matière euh pour me parlez des
des des ré enfin des des des des
chiffres qui ont été mentionné dans le
dans la presse sur des un nombre de
structures euh ouvertes ou gérées par le
cabinet mossac fonsseeka on un nombre de
460 structures euh moi je ne fais pas
commentaire sur ces 400 sur ce chiffre
de 460 moi je vous donne le le chiffre
tel que nous l'avons aujourd'hui nous
avons comme je disais aujourd'hui quatre
structures ouvertes non bloquées
euh pour dans dans ces 38 juridictions
je précise Queau titre de C parmi ces
quatre structures il y en a deux qui
sont des structures panaméennes et deux
autres dans d'autres juridictions que
que que que Panama euh et je ne voilà je
voilà voilà les informations aujourd'hui
en terme de photographie que nous avons
à la suite d'un programme mis en place
donc depuis depuis un certain nombre
d'années je crois que les les chiffres
que vous enfin qui ont été mentionnés
dans la presse remontent semble-t-il à
1980 je je ne sais pas je ne peux pas
faire de commentaire sur sur ces sur ces
sur ces chiffres euh concernant les
trusts vous mentionnez un chiffre très
important de Trust gérés je répète que
nous ne gérons aucun trust pour des
résidents fiscaux français euh 90 % ou
87 % exactement des trustes que nous
gérons sont pour des résidents fiscaux
asiatique euh il y en a quelques-uns
pour des raisons fiscaux anglais
britanniques c'est leur loi euh et à
côté de ça quasiment rien euh au total
nous gérons 411 trust aujourd'hui entre
nos deux sociétés à Jersey et à
Singapour de 41 vous voyez est assez
loin du chiffre que vous avez mentionné
tout à
l'heure sur notre présence dans les
présence de groupe dans les dans les
état et territoire non coopératif au
sens de de de de la liste française vous
avez mentionné bruneil et Philippines je
je précise que la philippine est sortie
de la liste depuis depuis un certain
nombre d'années euh mais je vais
peut-être laisser Christian comelet vous
répondre spécifiquement sur cette
question de la présence du groupe NP
pariba dans ces territoires ETNC
oui donc le le le groupe se réfère se
réfère à deux à deux types de listes les
deux les deux listes officielle en la
matière donc celle qui est établie par
le Forum mondial de de de l'OCD
qui compte qui compte plus de 130
membres et qui pratique une analyse très
précise des textes et des pratiques des
des des États en matière d'assistance
administrative et puis celle de la
France donc la liste des des États et
territoires non coopératifs euh donc
nous le groupe n'est présent dans aucun
état jugé non conforme par le Forum
mondial de de l'OCDE et il est présent
dans deux États qui figurent sur la
liste des États et territoires non
coopératifs de la France qui sont
bruneille et le
Botswana donc ces éléments sont indiqués
sont indiqué en en toute clarté toute
transparence dans notre dans notre
rapport annuel au bruneil nous avons une
activité qui est essentiellement tournée
vers le fond souverain donc il n'y a
aucune activité au profit de au profit
de de non résidents et donc en aucun cas
c'est une activité qui qui est suscepti
de de permettre quelque évasion fiscale
que ce soit et au botsuana notre
présence est liée à une acquisition que
nous avons faite en Afrique du Sud et
nous avons une filiale au Botswana qui
est spécialisé dans le crédit à la
consommation et en fait nous faisons du
crédit pour l'équivalent en partenariat
avec l'équivalent local de Conforama
donc là encore le risque le risque
d'évasion fiscale est
nul le groupe en question précise en
fait est l'actionnaire de Conforama
c'est la c'est le même groupe que
Conforama la même la même société
d'accord je voudrais sur les caillement
monsieur le Président vous n'avez pas
répondu sur le les activités menées au
caillement et les raisons pour
lesquelles vous avez décidé de fermer
ses filiales au CA je je pense avoir
répondu sur détail sur
le j'aimerais apporter une précision à
notre commission sur les caillement je
viens de vérifier là la liste et il
semblerait bien que ne figure pas et
même n'ont pas figuré sur la liste
française des
ETNC alors est-ce qu'il a un problème de
transparence avec ce pays qui aurait mal
encontreusement échappé à notre
administration fiscale non c'est le pays
qui
reçit
voilà là-dessus donc làdessus les
caillements donc depuis 2005 sont
engagés dans les changes automatique
dans le cadre de la directive épargne
depuis 2009 ils ont signé avec la France
un accord d'échange de renseignement qui
a toujours fonctionné à la satisfaction
des autorités françaises en 2013 comme
le rappelait Jacques desty ils ont été
évalué par le Forum mondial qui les ont
considéré comme comme conforme et en au
G20 de 2014 à Berlin ils se sont engagés
parmi les juridictions pionnières pour
une généralisation de l'échange
automatique d'information il y a
peut-être juste un point sur lequel je
voudrais revenir dans les dans les
questions du du du sénateur é qu'on
qu'on n pas évoqué qui était la question
de de l'impact de l'amende en France et
donc là je je je souhaite je souhaite
confirmer ce qui avait déjà été dit que
en aucun cas cette amende n'a eu un
impact négatif sur la base imposable en
France hein puisque elle n'a pas été
déduite sur sur ce dernier point
concernant le le
le la procédure du département de
américain en Suisse benp pariba fait
partie en benp PR Suisse a été impliqué
au même titre que toutes les banques
privées opérant sur le territoire suisse
donc parmi toutes les banques privées
opér en Suisse il y a benp pariba que
dans le dans ce programme ce programme
n'a pas mentionner pays sous sanction ça
n'a pas de lien avec des pays sous
sanctions américaines c'était un
programme de conformité fiscale des
résidents américains ayant des comptes à
l'étranger donc tout à fait quelque part
vu de
desés le sujet qui nous préoccupe
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle qu'il a une
petite spécificité pour les les les
résidents américains ou les nationaux
américains c'est que les Américains sont
imposé mondialement quel que soit leur
lieu de de résidence donc ça ça y a un
spectre beaucoup plus large de de
fonctionnement de cette
disposition bon dans dans dans ce
programme qui conci toutes les banques
suisses opér en Suisse il y avait une
première catégorie catégorie 1 d'une
dizaine de banques les banques les plus
exposées BNP pariba ne fait pas partie
de cette ne faisait pas partie de cette
de cette liste et nous avons totalement
coopéré avec le département de jusce
américain d'ailleurs je vous vous pouvez
vous référer au statement of fact qui a
été publié sur le site du du département
de justice qui soulligne à la fois le
bon comportement de la banque en terme
de d'accompagnement de C clients sur sur
la sur la en terme de conformité fiscale
et
également le salue la la coopération de
la banque avec les aute américaines dans
dans ce dossier donc et à nouveau donc
pas pas de lien avec des pays sous
sanction et à nouveau pas d'impact c'éit
une amende qui était payée par benp par
Suisse et qui n'est pas déductible en
France donc il a pas aucun impact sur la
fiscalité
française merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur François Marc il sera suivi
d'Éric Doliger
oui merci présidente s'agissant de
l'offshore il y a en fait on peut dire
une offre et une
demande et et et donc une sorte de
marché où on met
en en face à faceace offreurs et
demandeurs les demandeurs ce sont les
les chercheurs de de quiétude
réglementaire et fiscal mais en un
certain nombre et puis les offreurs ce
sont ces pays qui
veulent maximiser la qualité d'accueil
sur leur territoire pour qu'il ait un
maximum de de de d'acteurs qui viennent
y chercher cette quiétude tant souhaité
euh est-ce que sur ce terrain
euh ce nomadisme qui s'est accentué ces
dernières années est accompagné par
votre groupe est-ce que vous avez mis
quelques Haas
sur l'accompagnement des clientèles qui
sont à la recherche de cette quiétude au
fond est-ce que aujourd'hui
vous vous êtes en vous vous êtes mis en
réserve par rapport à cette pratique
de de de de cette clientèle à chaque
instant à la recherche de de l'optimum
dans certains paradis fiscaux euh
deuxème question porte sur le le Dakota
du Sud on sait qu'au Dakota du Sud les
avoirs bancaires protégés par des trusts
ont explosé ces dernières années euh
puisque ils sont passés de 33 milliards
de dollars en 2006 à 226 milliards en
2014 est-ce queà vos yeux le Dakota du
Sud
et la nouvelle Suisse ou le nouveau
Panama votre banque aelle proposer à ses
clients l'ouverture de Trust ou de
structure analogue dans cet état c'est
un point sur lequel on aimerait être
éclairé merci merci Monsieur le
Directeur bien je répondre sur le sur le
votre première question sur
l'accompagnement de clients euh pour
l'ouverture de structures dans des pays
le nomadisme tel que pour le reprendre
le mot vous vous utilisiez euh je crois
que enfin j'étais assez clair je crois
sur la politique de la banque depuis
2013 euh nous avons une politique qui ne
de pas ouvrir de de de compte au nom de
société offshore euh dans l'une ou
l'autre de ces 38 juridictions qui est
un périmètre très très large he de de de
de toutes les juridictions euh qui sont
considérés comme étant potentiellement
des jurridictions à risque je dirais euh
donc pas d'accompagnement ça veut dire
enfin pas d'ouverture pas
d'accompagnement nous n'avons pas
d'activité
euh pour les résidents fiscaux- français
depuis 2013 je l'ai dit et notre
politique à l'avenir est de de n'avoir
pas d'ouverture ni pour les résidents
fiscaux- français ni pour résidents
fiscaux européens ni pour les résidents
fiscaux de de l'OCDE
euh à nouveau pour la partie asiatique
et eurocde je l'ai expliquaé tout à
l'heure les les il faut faire une
analyse un petit peu des des des
juridictions des cadres juridiques
successoral de tous les pays pour savoir
est-ce qu'il y a vraiment les outils
dans chacun de ces pays pour répondre
aux besoins des clients à Fort
patrimoine en tout cas en France donc
consid en France et en Europe il y a les
outils et donc il y a pas
d'accompagnement de notre part en la
matière pour ouvrir des structures
offshore pour nos clients sur la
question spécifique du Dakota du Sud euh
je ne suis pas familier avec cette cette
juridiction donc je il est difficile de
de de de répondre mais à nouveau c'est
c'est la même la même réponse nous
n'accompagnons pas n'accompagnerons pas
un client français pour une ouverture de
structure dans un dans un territoire qui
qui
serait ne fait pas partie de no 38 je ve
le dire mais si
si si ce que vous dites est vrai il
pourra en faire partie nous n'avons pas
de structure pour nos clients au Dakota
du Sud pour répondre à V questions
aujourd'hui français il n'y a pas de
client
français résident fiscaux français pour
lequel benp pariba a un compte au nom
d'une structure auakota du
Sud merci Éric Doliger oui merci Madame
la présid sera suivi d'André gatolin oui
merci madame la Présidente oui je me
permet de vous poser deux questions pour
avoir quelques quelques
précisions je voulais savoir si vous
avez ou aviez-vous eu recours ou non à
d'autres cabinets que mossac fonsseeka
au Panama ou ailleurs pour créer des
sociétés offshore des Trost ou des
fiduci et lesquel donc c'est ma première
question et la deuxième j'aimerais
également savoir si les obligations de
vigilance sont les mêmes quel que soit
l'état dans lequel est implantée la
filiale de la banque alors par exemple
lorsque le blanchiment de fraude fiscale
n'est pas incriminé et dans quelle
mesure vos filiales implantées dans
d'autres États sont-elles soumises aux
obligations de vigilance
française merci monsieur le directeur
pour répondre à votre première question
travaillonsnous avec d'autres cabinets
nous n'avons d'accord commercial ou de
relation particulière avec aucun cabinet
mossac Fonseca ou aucun
autre pour je précise que pour la la la
clientèle française pour donner une une
petite illustration de de notre activité
en la matière notre absence d'activité
en la matière
plutôt nous n'avons qu'un accord
commercial nous n'introduisons pas nos
clients à des cabinets sur mossac
fonseeka ou
d'autres sur le le stock de clients
Résid résidents fiscaux français euh
structure bloqué ou non bloqué je que
n'avions que quatre structures non
bloquées en existance aujourd'hui pour
résident fiscau français dans de à
Panama sur cet ensemble nous avons
identifié un client qui a utilisé mossac
Fonseca pour la gestion de sa structure
c'est une structure qui est d'ailleurs
bloquée chez nous depuis avril
2014 voilà le le le description de la de
la de la réalité je vous posz une
question savoir si toutes les toutes nos
filiales sont soumes aux mêmes
conditions queles que soient les règles
locales en terme de de qualification de
lutte de lutte contre la la prode fiscal
en terme de blanchiment la réponse est
oui nous appliquons la même strictement
les mêmes règles mondialement pour ce
qui concerne le groupe BP
par merci André gatolin oui merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur
le Directeur général ou directeur
général adjoint voilà euh vous avez
évoqué dans votre présentation plusieurs
éléments et vous avez dit depuis 2013 on
nouvre plus de compte offshore pour des
résidents français finaux donc à
forciorie vous en offourez est-ce que
vous en ouvrez pour des résidents
français non Finau ou est-ce que
d'autres se chargent dans dans le monde
et dans l'offre globale bancaire voir
d'accords internationaux de les ouvrir
pour ces résidents finaux vous avez dit
concernant je voudrais soubl je réponde
tout de suite à cette question que on
som des gens assez sérieux oui quand je
vous dis qu'il n'y a pas d'ouverture il
n'y a pas d'ouverture et les ce qui
compte lorsqu'on parle de structure
c'est le bénéficiaire économique final
d'accord donc nous n vons pas de
structure pour les Béné
pour dont les bénéficiaaires économiques
ultim sont des résidents fiscaux
français pas il n'a pas eu d'exception
depuis
2013 trs cldord veux pas de pas ultime
pas final enfin ce qui compte c'est le
bénéficiaire à la fin qui est le qui est
le le vrai bénéficiaire de la structure
si nous si nous ne connaissons pas ce ce
ce bénéficiaire nous n'aurons pas de
compte lorsque nous le connaissons nous
exigeons la la la la confformité fiscale
depuis 2013 il n'y a pas d'ouverture
d'accord des résidents fiscaux français
ok euh vous avez évoqué le cas de de de
cession effectivement de de de filial de
depuis ces derniers dernières années
certaines sont en extinction d'autres
sont en session et vous dites les liens
ont été stoppés aux entreprises les
liens ont été stoppés avec les
entreprises auxquelles elles ont été
cédé alors je posais tout à l'heure la
même question à Monsieur
Brassac donc du Crédit Agricole et je
demandais si ce qu'on appelle lien
commerciaux c'est simplement il y a pas
de lien capitalistique où vous renvoyez
pas des
clients ou si ça concernait un transfert
de personnel et à l'occasion il a
reconnu que le personnel faisait partie
de la session aux gens à qui s'était
cédé et il a même dit que il y avait une
personne encore détachée du du Crédit
Agricole pour assurer le bon passage des
clients donc est-ce que vous avez
vous-même ce type de pratique ou est-ce
que vous êtes plus vertueux que ce que
j'ai bien cru comprendre qui nous avait
été dit par le directeur
du Crédit Agricole et puis enfin je suis
un petit peu gêné tout à l'heure quand
on a évoqué effectivement des
entreprises qui n'étaient pas dans la
considation parce que leur volume
d'affaires était trop faible il y a
quand même dans ces services qui ont été
rendu par des banques ou qui sont
toujours rendu par des banques une
dimension de conseils gratuit dans
l'optimisation fiscale donc dans la
mesure où c'est gratuit ça fait pas
l'objet d'une
contractualisation sachant que la banque
qui favorise euh d'une certaine manière
je dirais l'optimisation ou l'évasion
fiscale de ces client n'est pas perdante
en terme de compte quand même euh
qu'elle a à gérer donc euh je voudrais
être sûr que quand une filiale n'est pas
consolidée c'est qu'elle a réellement
des activités réelles et non pas parce
que euh elle offre euh des service voilà
je vous remercie monsieur le directeur
je je va vous répondre sur la sur la la
la la première question et Christian
COMEL répondra sur la sur la deuxème
alors sur la prè question je je voudrais
vous remercier chaleureusement de me
permettre de revenir sur ce sujet des
des société de gestion administrative de
de de enfin de de société offshore quand
je dis que nous avons cédé nous avons
cédé vous AZ parlé d'extinction non il y
a pas extinction nous avons cédé une
société donc de l'instant où elle est
cédé nous n som plus le propriétaire n
somt plus le gestionnaire nous ne sommes
plus responsables donc je ve bien que ce
soit clair et lorsque nous cédons une
société effectivement nous cédons pas un
bâtiment avec des murs enfin des bureaux
vides le personnel est évidemment garde
son emploi dans la dans la société et
simpl travaille pour une société qui est
détenue par un nouvel actionnaire c'est
bien comme ça que ça que se passe il n'y
a pas de détaché BNP Paribas dans ces
structuresilà il n'y a pas du tout et et
nous n'avons pas comme n n'ons pas
d'éléments qui nous permettent de penser
que il y ait des liens entre les
personnels enfin il y a pas de politique
avoir des liens entre BNP parba et ses
société et n'ont pas d'élément pour
penser qu'il y en a au niveau des des
des individus qui travaillent d'un côté
chez BP pariba aujourd'hui et d'autres
des individus ou des des personnes qui
ont été fait partie du personnel des
sociétés qui ont été vendu j'espère je
être le plus clair possible sur ce sujet
parce que c'est c'est important merci
beaucoup monsieur Comolet oui merci
madame la Présidente oui donc sur le sur
la seconde question euh je dirais que le
le encore une fois l'enjeu l'enjeu
fiscal il est nul dans la mesure où les
entités où les entités en question sont
sont sont sont taxés aux États-Unis mais
pour être très précis sur la question de
la
consolidation le groupe BNP bariba il a
deux caractéristiques en la matière la
première c'est qu'il a un taux de
consolidation enfin un seuil de
consolidation qui est très bas et la
deuxième c'est que ce seuil il est
parfaitement
transparent dessus et il le publie dans
dans dans son rapport annuel ce seuil en
fait il suffit que vous atteigiez 1
million d'euros de résultats pour être
consolidé à l'ône d'un groupe comme BNP
paribba vous voyez qu'on est dans un
rapport de 1 à 10000 par rapport par
rapport au résultat au résultats global
donc c'est dire que on ne prend on prend
en
compte absolument tout ce qui a tout ce
qui est un temps soit peu significatif
et il n'y a vraiment que que les que les
les éléments totalement dépourvus de de
de de de matérialité comme on dit en
mauvais franglais qui qui reste qui
reste à
l'écart merci un point de de pour
répondre totale et complète à votre
question benp pariba n'offre pas de
service de conseil fiscal à ses clients
vous savez qu'en France toutçon cette
profession est totalement réglementé n
sommes pas som pas agrémentés pour pour
donner à nos clients
des des services de conseil fiscal merci
Monsieur leeur moi j'ai une dernière
question nous l'avons évoqué tout à
l'heure la semaine dernière nous
recevions ici le secrétaire général de
la CPR qui nous av fait part de
difficultés qui temps en temps qualifié
d'alarmante auquel régulateur se en
matière de coopération internationale
entre régulateurs donc j'aimerais que
vous nous disiez ement comment se
passent les contrôles la CPR sur vos
filiales au sein de l'Union européenne
je suppose vous allez me répondre que
c'est en fonction des des législations
des pays mais lorsquun contrôle est
effectué par la CPR quelles sont les
relations de votre filiale avec le
régulateur local qui a formé de la
démarche et comment notamment sont
sélectionnés les
échantillons et des informations
nominatives peuvent-elles être remonté
au régulateur français et vous quel
consiges donnez-vous en cas de contrôle
sur place ça c'est une question typique
pour mon voisin de droite
éc Martin responsable de la conformité
benp paribba voilà Monsieur éc Martin
bien je vais vous faire part un peu de
notre expérience non pas de régulateur
mais de réguler puisque la CPR a dû
passer au cours des dernières années
notamment dans des missions liées à à la
banque privée
internationale à Jersey à Singapour à
Hong Kong à Luxembourg en Suisse et à
Monaco donc d'une de manière
générale ça se passe l'accès se passe
bien à ma connaissance il a eu deux
particularités celle où le la CPR s'est
heurté à la contrainte la plus forte en
matière d'accès à une information
nominative sur les clients c'est la
Suisse et pour répondre à votre
question ilur notre demande le
management local avait essayé
d'intercéder auprès du régulateur Suisse
mais bon sans succès euh sur le
Luxembourg c'est un peu différent
c'est dans le cadre de la mission qui a
eu lieu à Luxembourg euh un échantillon
avait été préparé sur base non
nominative mais dès lors qu'il a été
choisi par la CPR euh à ma connaissance
la CPR avait accès au dossier sur base
nominative voilà ce qui est donc quand
même une étape supérieure et ensuite bon
ensuite mais après c'est plus pour la CV
c'est une question de de relation entre
régulateurs sur base de
réciprocité voilà dans les l'expérience
que l'expérience dont dont je peux vous
faire part sur les les missions récentes
ENF depuis quelques années merci
beaucoup voilà pour cette matinée
consacrée aux travaux de la commission
des finances sur l'évasion fiscale avec
ses audition du Crédit Agricole et de
BNP paribbas vous pouvez toujours voir
et revoir toutes les audition sur notre
site
publsenap.fr très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaires